welcome everybody to another episode of
the h3 podcast here with the illustrious
Eric hey Hofstadter guys ela Klein what
a pillock liners is and the biggest pimp
Jessie well is what up here this episode
is also sponsored by Bethesda that's
pretty dope their new game Elder Scrolls
legends SeatGeek
and wink more about that later but until
then let's get right into the news by
you and Jessie so thanks for joining us
thanks for having me I'm real excited
did I made it a cable all the way out
here I never walk away from Venice I
feel nervous because Jesse is the
original what a big pink that's true
I am was what up cheeps yeah and I would
always intro my vilasa will up oops is
my vlog it's just such a it's a powerful
way to wake them up you know I mean me
and me and Ian idubbbz wanted to make
like a parody of like YouTube vloggers
right and it didn't really come out good
it was kind of a bad video so the words
lettuce yeah first video we made to get
everyone everyone's like you and Ian
made a video and it's super
disappointing so that was comic but
anyway this was mad the babies are so
off the really better base anyway but we
did this thing what up pimp yeah and the
hundred times yeah now every single is
but you know when do your YouTube daily
vlogger you always feel like you have to
do the same exact thing every morning
but you don't every started a video I
don't know why you don't have to well
but you just yeah I just got here start
the video so I do that one weird intro
the thing is like because starting
videos is really hard it's awkward
awkward so I think a lot of youtubers
have like top of the morning to you
laddies are be really nice because it
gives you that end yeah okay that's not
the way now yeah start that's true
because otherwise it's just like okay
well now I do weird [ __ ] like I'll just
like walk into frame and like I haven't
made a video
three weeks hey hey let me dust this off
yeah we still don't have we didn't have
an intro until we did the water based oh
my and now attention I was doing I want
10%
do you ever where you start your video
there uh yeah I say I say hello you're
watching internet comment etiquette with
Eric Marek your host it's always some
variation of that but it's the same
thing you're talking about like yeah
it's a good way to get into it need to
get and it is about starting with like a
dramatic cold open like show likes
someone finding a body in a construction
site you know and you think you're about
to watch they can episode of law and
order or something like that but it just
goes to me
so I got your comments you need to do
one of these always me I thought I was
married my god we go no no because you
told me about it
you told me that actually makes a lot of
sense yeah like I I respected your
experience way more when I watched your
video about because I think that that
was so it was spectacular it was sort of
like tacular you know that oh yes you're
welcome
you'd say lies now I'm better if you had
just spun around and been like what okay
I was about to default to you know what
I want to do if you're up for it yeah
what I want to put that on and get a
play-by-play
this isn't that serious I think if any
color if anything it will accelerate you
I like you know I'm into it and I think
that the way you owned it was like
wonderful for you I think it was a win
it was embarrassing as it is and I've
done a lot of embarrassing [ __ ] on the
internet so I'm kind of used to it but
the hardest part was like after I did
that I had to go back out into that
place and play a game in front of all
creators oh yes like that sound as I go
and look at me right now I know I done
[ __ ] up and Here I am nobody's right
and Sue you had a feeling
feeling after it happened I was like
sweating I was like [ __ ] because I rally
nobody watches the part where I actually
did good we all end it when I start
doing good yeah yeah so so I felt I
rallied I did okay at the end I asked my
buddy
he's like that was bad that was bad
oh well that was good well good app from
every Easter me there's always like an
amazing clip and you definitely I own
all of em dude I don't nobody remembers
anything about you three right wonderful
clip yeah well he was part of the
problem but it caught me off guard
so yeah done so when I watch this I
thought you're trying to be cool no like
this cold open you're like oh what up to
you I was like wait what alright and
that's because when they brought me out
there like you're gonna go on in about
15 minutes somebody else is going to
talk another trust going to play so I
was watching the show and the camera was
behind me and I was like ready like I
kept going through the lines in my head
and there was no other clip another
person talking and it's just the lights
fired on if you listen carefully you can
hear someone yell Jesse oh and I'm like
oh [ __ ] and I said you know I turn
around and it was like a deer in
headlights like I couldn't even see the
teleprompter like oh my god out and I
was like Jesse don't let the worst
nightmare happen to you it's happening
it's going to happen it's good it go in
a half philemon oh no oops my play with
sounds for the big fellas I wasn't
supposed to say what up like that
no I with the default mode so what
happened did they screw up or like it
seemed like there was a mistake where
you you you didn't know you're ready to
go yeah yeah I know yeah look I didn't
know I was completely caught off guard
like I said I thought another trailer
and another person was going to speak
before I went on right you know how like
you kind of prepare yourself mentally
every about to speak absolutely and I'm
like just going over the one word in my
head that would help the whole thing
flow so when she was like more people
are coming on don't worry you have a
little bit of time I'll tell you right
before you come on other okay let me
just know unplug for a minute
a show not sit there and stress about a
tumor right and I was in unplug mode
window just feels like yeah oh my god
what up oops
it's way too relatable I think you're
watching this whole neck never want to
host anything by it
well god yeah guys why I have no idea
what I'm supposed to do it now a YouTube
creator so I am here to Leslie looking
at the teleprompter going that is not
anything that I'm supposed to say right
now oh yeah
right now yeah I was like and I wasn't
caught up on the teleprompter because I
was caught off-guard because I didn't
even know so what I couldn't find
anything else versus let other people
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know I
couldn't even like figure it out fast
enough they're like what and then and
I'm looking I'm like it's not what was I
and I didn't even need it though I
actually remembered it but it's so
stressed and your situation you're not
even like it's just a panic yeah I told
I would have done the same thing
that's why watching this was like so
relatable because I think what happened
in its a full system failure I was need
for speed well I just wanted that it a
little creative editing you know better
than that
no I'm out I'm out I want the original
yeah I don't know it's hard to find the
raziel why is that so III original but I
like I kind of stutter my words about
that but because I was going to say damn
I'm in my head I foot I'm bombing oh my
god this bomb it's against my head
bombing the Bombers
crashing and burning a little bit so
good bombing of guns
thank you for having me
garbled Alya my name is jesse wellens
and i am a YouTube creator so right now
you're just trying to improvise tryna
fear and the problem was I would then
write my script I just showed up as a
would want me to say and I should have
wrote it myself but what's the same
thing on scripture was that improvised I
don't remember I think that was on
script like they wanted me to tell
everyone that Who I am I'm a youtube
person and I my name is Jesse and then
it was like I forget what the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to say now but I like when I
when I've got to need for speed and that
I just blanked I supposed to talk about
like me and the producer we're going to
go drive cars and I was gonna make a
video about it is that and the other and
here he is like that's what it was
supposed to be so let me let me let you
relive this nightmare I'm here to talk
about Need for Speed payback if you guys
didn't know achieved a minute Bobby
crime bombing I'm about to crash right
now just coming with me but the
seatbelts on the [ __ ] little
ventilation thing drops we're going down
because amazing speeds excite camera or
just shows you going on the road like
exploding injury like yeah you're
laughing I'm not you have been big
enough where it's over Didier should
giving you a bonus for this I know cause
like all these gamers talked about Need
for Speed I think they kind of did i
pre-ordered it shout out I didn't cook I
did coach Jesse Wong I created it 20
times we're trying to get you a raise I
love how you try to acknowledge like
there laughter yeah being for like oh
yeah the clapping for the king and not
trying to encourage me yeah there's
another Greek a bigger but I also design
I mean to creator a child I tried to
reset them so we're all supposed to be
good maybe I'll roll off
I think once you're in that moment they
thought you're just [ __ ] it's done
yeah you get out as cleanly as ya
I'm bombing very good local Bay did that
she just starts he gets flustered and
then he's just like I'm out thank God
I mean it's [ __ ] like Axl Rose can do
it like in the middle of the concert
although he got hit with a rock
I'm sorry that's a tangent that's a
little bit he got hit the rock and then
walked offstage yeah I'm sorry dude
well nobody had next time have a plant
some what the rock some over the rocks
and I just in case you start bombing and
nail you with it you're like sorry I got
to go say I did this suddenly care
laughter on rock they're coming out I am
my boy Marcus executive producer here he
is the producer of the game the
exploration I had to introduce somebody
else right after him they nicked yeah
I'm already fast forward in it as I said
Marcus and I'm like oh [ __ ] not yet it's
not your fault all over my ass about the
ton of weed the night before yeah it was
done not I didn't just heard about that
idea I thank God I was I had to get
there I was tough man and then Teen
Choice Awards asked me to come present
on their show live is yeah like resume
with her if you all see me live I'm
really good yeah and they all started
laughing I'm like I guess they didn't
sit are you gonna do it no I'm not doing
it I'm just gonna do it in some
self-aware why yeah on fun yeah you got
a trip hole dude everyone's going to
tune in oh yeah well I was like yeah
definitely has to have me come back next
year
absolutely like and I should just screw
really bad just yet amazing if it was
like a song and dance number that like
[ __ ] nailed it like before [ __ ] you
really know what they're trying to tell
people is not to bet on purpose they're
like yeah right there's no way you
connect a good and verbally right
right I gotta tell you this thing hit
and like I mean we're friends and I was
like goo but they're like you owned it
you made this great video about it and I
tip my Fedora Saran
you owned it and it was it just turned
out a lot I mean it's just fun I thought
it was so fun I gotten it as we left I
was like Zac we got to leave I can't be
here much longer
and we got it over and we're leaving and
I'm like he filmed it for me too like
when we play back I want to watch it and
we were just crying I was yeah this is
my day one home in for 30 years so if
anyone can laugh at me and be him and
and he was so you eighty is fine I'm
like bro this might go really viral so
I'm like getting excited I'm like in the
car I like I'm actually kind of happy
like then I saw the PewDiePie did a
video about him like oh god okay and we
watch it and he was nice I was like okay
I'm happy because we are all related
yeah all of that can relate me like I
could so easily be there can any of us
yeah I mean when they when they brought
it up to you were like super excited
you're like [ __ ] yeah that sounds
awesome
well you know what I really wasn't fully
aware of what I was getting myself into
they're like hey we want you to present
it EA like I didn't know a lie was I
never watched it and they're like
present and tie and I've done stuff like
that before and I was fine live stuff
I've done like speaking engagements and
I was fine it was just like the
combination of getting caught off guard
and the teleprompter relying on that was
like a recipe for disaster yeah and then
I'm like did they set me up be like Joe
we need a fall guy this year you need a
really good fall guy damn it we will
switch game needs a lot of help this
year need for speed demon speeds yeah we
don't win we need it we need to spice it
up yeah we need a big cringy one I'll
get Jessie oh you know I'll get them off
guard if that's not true take note other
game developers right add them up higher
Jesse and knock them down but yes I mean
you know the base actually sounded
really great base was on the bases on
about radio voice but not face well
moving on you are not making daily blogs
anymore no how is life now because you
are you used to be a daily vlogger and I
know that that grind is in
to the level that people can't even
understand yeah it was everyday bro
Brown yeah everyday no hey do we have
the sound work do you have not have a
everyday bro sound effect we have done
breath step it up did but when I did
when I was doing it thank you thank you
we got a sound board but it's like it's
just surprising right it today I just
forgot that in the song shout said oh no
I edited tota
I made the feeding and researching well
good I wanted to drink Thank You active
we're here anyway where were we daily
vlogging yeah I mean when I see when I
was doing it wasn't like a thing as I
good as now like everybody in her mom's
daily ha ding yeah that's actually true
logo
Jake and their mom that really really
everyone in their mom hey when I'm out I
just started it was Charles Trippy and
shaycarl are the holy guys that really
did it on the internet they kind of
inspired me and uh
rest in peace shaycarl yeah I haven't
smoked him in a while but he's like the
og of the daily vlog and Charles Charles
Trippy hasn't actually missed the day to
this day he's been doing like 10 years
straight
that is banana oh yeah I don't know I
don't know I lost my mind after 6:00 so
well I was telling you me and Ella did
daily videos on our second channel
eating Neela for 30 days and we almost
got a divorce is stressful it's a lot
but I can't live your life like there's
no way well you start blurring the lines
between reality and and that's going
through this camera lens and how you're
just like living life so it's almost
like am i doing this because I want to
do is am I doing this because I'm making
a video and if you do it every day
well yes goodnesses and mess your mental
health up I'm pretty sure no like how
was your relationship at the mic
throughout all that like you guys were
doing it for how long they did yeah we
did like six years straight and I mean
it was great everything was fine we were
doing I mean the benefits of it we were
like doing a lot more stuff than we
wouldn't have done you know we would
have sat on the couch that day instead
we got outside and did something here
doing so it was it was really good for
that we I experienced more than I'm sure
a lot of people have ever experienced in
their six years because I was always
trying to do so
than different everyday uh but it like
put in your life on the internet and
having people comment on how you should
live your life and you actually doing it
you know every day bro is not healthy so
at what point did it start to feel like
this is not healthy anymore like when my
mom passed away and I'm like going like
what the [ __ ] am i doing like I should
be spending more time with family than
what figuring out how am I going to make
another video everyday or or like I need
to just stop living through this camera
lens and just live life without it and
just and that's that's when I was just
like I just stopped it after that
because I'm just like what am I going to
vlog tomorrow my mom just passed away
I'm gonna [ __ ] get on camera and act
all happy and like [ __ ] this what is it
even if you want to be sad that's also
not not really something that I didn't
wanna share my personal [ __ ] you know
I'm done I can't do it anymore like this
super said that was the breaking point
that your mom okay and it was like no
more daily you vlog but um did you vlog
after that happened after special
earther stopped writer
oh that good and then what happened when
not actually no I did blog a little bit
after that I did I did but like and
wonder was a big secret I'm not gonna
say on here but like me and my
relationship my life was like not the
same that's the internet thought it was
so we let your marital are you yeah like
my my situation with my ex and all like
we were kind of keeping a lot of things
personal and then we finally released
the internet like we were actually
broken up so you guys were leading on
that it was all good for them yeah for a
while yeah and it was like this is we
gotta just not yeah and I felt like that
was just not healthy for us to is it
like trying to grow and figure things
out so you had mentioned something to me
previously when we were chatting that I
thought was really interesting about
like think you were talking about like I
want to get a dog but I know if I want
the dog for the vlog or for myself yeah
yeah I thought that was really
interesting well yeah I mean I do want a
dog but I would flock the [ __ ] out of
the dog because I think a great content
but but I'm so busy so but I do want a
dog but I got a roommate now so I might
put it on him when I try how bad do you
think it is because there's some daily
vloggers do you ever
think that it goes to the point we're
like are we having this kid for the vlog
or because I want more kids yeah I mean
that's it's scary to think about that's
got to be something I mean I guarantee
in the back of someone's brain that's a
daily vlogger and if they have a child
they're already taken all more views
more views and like that I mean I would
say you know saint roman atwood dude had
[ __ ] kids he put this guy it's so bad
for him that he had a new kid mmm and
they had a livestream
when the baby was born they decide the
baby's name ya know his fans decided his
baby's name and her livestream that's
how a little done for this dude and I
when I watch Roman out what I'm like
these guys all hate each other there's
no like I don't know that's good
anything you gotta be careful with that
like that
I mean smile more my dad live streamed
it I didn't know that he had I saw it on
Twitter so I'm not a hundred percent
sure but what I know I said we're naming
our comes help us name our new baby yeah
and it seemed like a whole promotion for
like live yeah I saw that streaming on
at live now naming our new baby so it's
like he got a sponsor yep honey realize
this Gerber you know I just got another
one I used to want to sponsorship me
proposing to my girl that is crazy
amounts of money and I was like there's
no way that's my god I utilize people
saying how much they offer because I
think I find that fascinating
no it wasn't a set amount yeah but it
was it was going to be dumb money
how can you ballpark like if you're
comfortable be like hey I don't remember
exactly how many on this event give me
again it was definitely in late the
six-figure oh nice so like by that -
like monetized the proposal and
everything and I'm just like no I can't
even ask me that
yeah that's a shitty thing that like can
we just [ __ ] completely attack you up
at strings to you and just tell you how
the [ __ ] like we're not have to God I
got it within the circle you know the
guy that's like we're kind of close as
friends but I was just like I remember
like my lawyer was like dude what the
[ __ ] if you get
I'm going to ask you this but there's
Assam talking about that I'm like no and
it was just like yeah and that that was
a problem with our relationship is like
I was getting so much pressure to
getting married I'm like I'm here
because you all wanted me to get married
I going to marry because I won't get
married what's happening here
god forbid you have a [ __ ] terminal
illness or something the one I like live
stream is death it's not a [ __ ] gate
or a DML therapy session it's necessary
by Gatorade yeah I mean is this you got
to be careful with that and I think like
people just don't care and there's one
anything they can do and it's like it's
like you sell your soul and I can almost
admit that I sold my I feel like I we
sold our relationship for the Internet I
still had happened how do you feel about
your fans didn't consume that content do
you resent it at all no I mean they're
just they're just they're just going
with the flow it's like dig at the
inside window into someone's life and
age like it's like a friendship but they
don't know they don't know that their
struggles and what really goes inside
and so I'm excited they don't know what
it's like to get to like commented on
they just know what it's like to comment
right I mean so that right it's hard for
them to understand that like insatiable
did like desire they had to like consume
oh my god sorry I don't windows mind is
stealing and you probably out of my life
windows [ __ ] ate that anyway that
insatiable desire your fans have like
consumed the most personal like the more
you know the more vulnerable to that or
the more they like it I mean it's like
it's like The Truman Show or something
but terms like reality television but it
day it's real reality television but I
feel like that's changing now I feel
like these people that do vlogger it's
like they're scripting things and
they're they're faking marriages now and
getting married and cakepop you had a
marriage yeah like yeah I'm sure he
didn't actually matter really what right
I'm marryin you know yeah I don't I mean
I don't think so he sponsored it
some on you I think it was Carnival
Cruises but unlike his videos when he
was getting married if I got crazy views
I'm not doing that Lucy there
we had like 10 marriage videos and they
all broke like 10 million there's like
banana it was a bonanza
sounds like an arranged marriage yeah it
was right in our way sorry I'll take a
little shadow baby he's a great actor
and this is all fully scripted from him
I've been talking about game on the
podcast I just hope it yeah what do you
think that do you think like this is all
I think he's just blurred the lines
between reality and scripted [ __ ] and
he's living this life but he's living
the life for the Internet
I think I think that he's too [ __ ]
young he doesn't know how to be
responsible anything
he loves Fame he loves attention he
loves the money but like any gods I
think I was a lot of okay okay I feel
like the problem is that this guy's will
do stuff at any cost they have no morals
they have no like okay this is this is a
line that I want cross like we have some
lines like that I want to change it
right you have to set up for yourself
because you have respect for yourself
and for others and it's like it's a
problem because you have to set it for
yourself yeah it's like this kids they
just don't like they're too [ __ ]
young if I was 21 yeah I was ever saying
I would I wouldn't have any [ __ ]
filter they're already an [ __ ] that's
why with a piece of [ __ ] and and for one
way I can't blame these young guys lower
I don't know better but I but to answer
your question I do think that that's
just who he I don't even think that it
goes that far in his head I think that's
who he is I think that's who he is I
don't think he's capable or mature
enough to make a separation of like life
and on her life I don't think so I know
nobody edits their videos anywhere I
edited all mine for six years
oh they don't really lunch that [ __ ] I
mean who you guys but I mean like the
daily hog yeah yeah so that's yeah the
fact that you and I think Casey that was
the struggle of stressful part is like
making the video but in that night yeah
hosted in the morning and then doing it
again yeah you weren't you into board
that so much you're just losses start
losing your mind
it was always like I was 3m I didn't
vlog yet for today oh really [ __ ] what
are we going to do oh maybe we'll just
go run down in
Jim and play with the cats okay well we
get it done in an hour
Wow edit it post it okay and it works in
the word well it's a rough life man I do
not have a the daily vloggers even Big
Brother like throws games and do it you
know like that's one of the models of
like showing someone's life every day is
right at least they have like
competitions and stuff we're like oh
[ __ ] a house or something yeah yeah
they're stuck in the house
filming they're just living right yeah
like tune into the great they're not
filming there's a whole it being
different you're not the creative side
of and the only car it's only for a few
months it's not for sick for hip right
never
you ever feel I sometimes sometimes I
feel like the grind is rough man it's
like this self-imposed [ __ ] nightmare
sometimes the youtubes is like a bargain
you got to have it now right away fast
I'm so envious of people with TV shows
right because they do this they'll work
really hard for like six months make a
great show and then they're like six
months off and everybody comes back and
watch season two and I'm like god I
can't even go I can't even go anywhere
for like a week without my life being
feel like it's being ruined but you know
here we are complaining we have like the
best job in the world trying to look no
matter how successful you are in life
you have it you have the right to
complain but like youtubers have this
real weird worry that if they leave the
internet for three weeks that they're
complete audience is called but that's
not true I used to think like that and
then I was just like you know what I'm
not going to take like that anymore I
think the owner who I am they're not
going to forget Who I am
right I'll make a video but oh yeah I
remember Jesse right the helis remember
they'll always remember always remember
the time we don't mean yes he's on the
street um god I want to talk about the
shipping containers okay I just not
advancing I just blew my [ __ ] lot and
what is it and I feel like it's such a
symptom of our [ __ ] sick society
we're living in people are buying
shipping containers okay I learned about
this from Erica Bly again I know very
little but I know enough to get us to
the Google
yeah so so people are because they can't
afford houses who the [ __ ] afford a
house this this was brought up to me by
my friend
Tainan who was looking for a house and
he was like you know I had this
interesting idea found out this this
thing you can do we can buy like a plot
of land right you [ __ ] tear down
whatever is on that plot of land and
then you can buy shipping containers and
get them furnished to look like homes so
they put drywall on the inside they make
it look kind of nice on the outside they
weld the shipping containers together
sort of like a like connect us to Lego I
connect them yes like a legging together
well I think this is just but wait how
is that cheaper then because it's you
know my house because it's who's living
in a box of metal like people can't
afford houses that's why they buying
this [ __ ] because nobody can afford to
buy houses so you're like I'm gonna buy
a [ __ ] box of metal that if elected
like a pig ever gets struck by lightning
me my whole family will be fried
so that base and how is it even cheaper
if you gotta buy stuff you gotta buy
land
oh they're dope open yeah we should look
yeah I haven't seen a picture of what I
think it doesn't make sense to me that
people do because they're broke because
you still have to buy land and you still
have to do all this ten thousand for the
container you got to hook it up to the
grid you got to get a plumbing
electrical like this it's not I already
have when you get a house wait this
makes it more expense so apparently this
is one well at this point why not build
a [ __ ] house it looks like I okay
that's more of like they're showing that
you can recite these recycling zones
this is the shipping canner can is the
guy bananas the ship manners I look like
your [ __ ] and mother just buy a house
but you had a funny thought too like all
these radio waves bouncing off the metal
yeah you start here Alex Joe how many
more that's dope also the fact that
that's a lot was like 80
ties sex worker ghosts yeah who doesn't
make it on the Shaklee you know Jesse
how is it a death of couse that is this
round
I think we're missing something cuz I
don't think someone would do that
because they're broke yeah it's gotta be
having to be she know a look at this
okay look at this I can put you know I'm
not living
oh yeah look at the stairway - my
brother has been here let me a soon as
you walk in balcony that looks expensive
no it's more than that look expensive
looks like a high-class playground it
seems like this is the kind of idea that
you would go down to be like oh this
might be a cheap alternative to cows and
then you start really looking at the
numbers and you're like oh this is twice
as expensive as a house and it's a
hundred degrees when it's 40 degrees
outside of yeah I don't have made of
[ __ ] metal freezes in the winter what
kind of house do you live in these days
there oh it's made of metal that big
metal box shipping containers it's so I
I asked my brother because he works in
architecture and he said it's cheaper
than building a house yeah that's why
that's why people do it right look at
this it looks like a [ __ ] house you
would see on a construction set it's
like a ready player right Jess you go by
and Emmas around and I would live in oh
look how [ __ ] luxurious this is this
is what they really look like yeah this
is saying you can isolate it it's a
project doing some Russian that one's
not working because that's there's no
wall yeah that's a guest room that's how
they come that's what they do cuz it
gets so hot they put they end up tearing
the wall down well I mean anyone there I
mean people in Venice are living in the
storage building we you know like you
can store your stuff oh [ __ ] I saw it
they're living in those I saw a video of
somebody who had that hooked up that way
they're living in like storage centrally
right like that yeah
very loud I'm sure like they live on
front of them in Venice but they're all
lined up so I figured that did have
enough money to rent a thing to put
their stuff in and they just go in there
and get stuff and then live in a tent
out front of it this world and Wow I saw
a video of a dude who was in one of
those storage units and he had it decked
out man he was like pulling stuff off
the wall you like built into it so that
there was a bed he live here there was
like a big jug a little bit sorry
sellers that looks ridiculous yeah with
your thing goes it looks absolutely
it looks like a it looks like a
McDonald's Playhouse I'm sorry we can't
do square windows
that expensive [ __ ] just put a ton of
them under the freeway and then just
move all the homeless people it looked
right houses it was really like if
somebody kicks one of those ways and you
have your whole house mumbling down like
a block of Legos I got one note less
windows plus maybe it's a different
shade on windows I don't on but it looks
like the dream hotel when you're I don't
know if you've been there
I'm not staying there good circle that
you don't like that already but they are
insulated just to Garret [ __ ] anyway I
thought it was fascinating so here's the
deal here's what we're going to do now
didn't take a little commercial break
really fast
two minutes and then I want to ask you
about the story when you got questioned
by the Secret Service for your Trump
assassination music video with because I
have yes told it with this story in
[ __ ] the fascinating so don't go away
and the meantime let me just thank our
sponsors really fast
if Union and yeah you go to bathroom
right thank you guys oh my gosh okay let
me just boss through this for a moment
right to you by story spread rocky but
we store dead type prostitutes and then
you live in this graveyard 800,000 we go
year oh oh I got you okay alright at
first uh guys I want to thank our
sponsor Bethesda oh my goodness Bethesda
one of my favorite companies ever got in
touch with us and they have a new card
game called Elder Scroll legends and
I've been playing this game for the past
couple days and it's basically it's an
online card game it's super fun
it's got all kinds of sexy card memes
that you would expect and they've got
some kind of fun game mechanics like
different lanes and stuff like that
anyway it's free to play it's out on
every single platform Steam Mac iOS
Android tablet phones and here's what's
so dope this is what I was doing play on
my tablet and then if I go out somewhere
you can close it on your tablet open it
on your phone or steam or your computer
and it will pick up right where you left
off when you log in it's very cool and
very fun if you love Skyrim and Bethesda
in the elder scrolls in this whole world
you're going to love this card game so
if you go to Bethesda dotnet and open an
account you're going to freakin
of the heck out of it and let me tell
you what else to which drops this is
really cool never to this if you watch
someone on twitch playing this game
Elder Scrolls legends you get free drops
in the game are people getting dressed
right now I'm being logged man that's a
good question I think I haven't be
playing the game yeah there's no like
humongous drops go now that would have
been dubbed though but if you're if
you're watching someone streaming it
then you you'll get it you'll get drops
I think if you attach your twitch says
I'm pretty freaking dope
they are updating the game all the time
you guys there's new cards every month
it's a whole toot and a riot
I've been enjoying the they have an
arena like PvP and they also have an
arena PvE so you can just match up
against NB NPC's to practice you get
good and still get fat loot had a lot of
fun I appreciate Bethesda and the Elder
Scroll Legends is a great game that will
be having you laughing and Gaffin and
giggling for hours and hours and hours
it's free go play the freaking thing
thank you to Bethesda next up I was very
nice about PvP what like pry first
product I used PvP oh that's like a
video game term and I didn't know that I
made a t-shirt like when I first gotta
start on YouTube and then what's my went
to playlist live the first year and this
kid was wearing my teachers at PvP FTW
[ __ ] does Maxim I got my shirt and I
walk up to my yo what's up P he's like
oh we really would I'm like the shirt
bro he's like player vs. player I'm like
you got a bomb like and bothered the win
I was like kind of disappointed in look
it reached outside holidays I guess
that's a good thing with you know a guy
came to find you later it was like ah
okay
I see here inactivated [ __ ] is a really
weird and I thought where in my
merchants
I did not mind because I knew who I was
wait it was actually your shirt it was
my shirt oh I know why you did PvP for
the wind yeah and GW it was like the Run
DMC lo let it yeah and I sold it through
district lines and they put on playlist
live it was the first year they did play
this live and I'm walking like no one
knows me so I can walk freely around and
I saw some guy wearing house it oh stop
yes not merciful to fear it was like a
real fire oh look at that
I grabbed my t-shirt that's [ __ ]
awesome nectar God shirt back next up we
have the great great company known as
seat geek C cake is an app that
aggregates tickets to live events from
all over the web to make buying as
simple as eating pie I got my Burnham
into heavy gamer during a sea kick I did
they're great they're really good C cake
is dealt because if you buy seats to an
event you can basically see the score on
the ticket so if you're buying a seat in
a auditorium or a stadium they'll give
you a 0-200 score to let you know how
good the deal is Green is good red is
bad that's intuitive you guys come on so
it's really and you get to like see the
view from the seat it's very cool so if
you go to see geek and you enter the
code h3h3 you get $20 off your first
order that's good whatever tonight uh
there's a link in the description to
download the app so I think like ckick
is dope it's it's kind of a new way of a
thing it's like a much better service
then traditionally you would find from
these other ticket guys and less like I
think some of the other guys actually
have like they have like slaves they're
like Chinese slave oh my god no it's
easy to Saul in the app because yeah I
really want to go to the show you just
pull it open boom you can find it dragon
- it's not like I'm not paying you by
the way this week at recess no I mean
it's true
oh listen I'm trying to get em be a
finals but alone I think your favorite
yeah and if and if she cake appreciates
Jessie get in touch when they get this
man some tickets but he said they have
been hooking me up I went to Hamilton
oh god you tickets to Hamilton was it
great cool was this great as everyone
says cool I said it to close so when you
go sit in the middle
do you think that that is your flash son
yeah I was in the classes and I break it
and [ __ ] out unit on but I was like that
also uh it's a small theater I went to
New York City so smoke to either I've
seen I've listened the soundtrack is
really yeah and the music's amazing yes
though it was good and I don't really
know a little use ultra but I like that
one see me good luck everyone yeah yeah
at the top it's all over folks the
extent of some freaking Alexander
tickets and everyone else go to see cake
if you want to go to Burning Man watch a
show watch Hamilton
see a freaking Dodgers game wherever you
are go Dodgers [ __ ] the Dodgers whatever
you want I don't have a stake in this
get $20 off your first purchase link in
the description just code hdhd thank you
I was wondering how you're funding the
fact that I yeah yeah this alright next
up we have week which is a really
interesting company they do this cool
thing where you go on their website try
wink calm slash h3h3 and you end up are
no sorries just ht3
we gotta get some consistency or these
guys just h3 all of them are just h3 we
need some consistency here now this one
I'm afraid
just h3 but they do this really cool
thing they deliver wine to you and you
go on and you take this quiz this pallet
quiz and they say D like berries do you
like dirt most people probably say no to
the dirt one yeah but that's ordinary
questions for dirt is it do you like
earth earth I know they always say
earthy yeah I don't I think that was
like do like coffee yeah chocolate
chocolate eclair YZ earth hazelnut rocks
rocks they've all these creations air do
you like air anyway they test your
palate and then they send you a bun
wine selection based on your palate it's
really dope we did it
and we got four balls one it was like I
was like oh my god these are so matched
to my palate this is a perfect match
so everyone you have to go to the store
I don't know what wine I'm doing I don't
know like you know but it's fun because
you can do a little wine tasting exactly
experience I like wine but I don't know
anything about wine so I go to the store
and I'm like what do I know
so these guys I think you don't have to
go to the store they take all that
process out of you
they don't think about the palette
enough like we rock you like rocks you
like her dress she grass easily betters
you like to taste the feathers you get
then we got the wine for so go to try
wink calm /h 3 and let's see here you
get 20 bucks off if you use that link on
your first order they'll even cover the
cost of shipping so go to TR y winc comm
/h 3 get $20 off and free shipping are
you guys spamming it out there Dan it's
showing on the screen also um what else
was going to say yeah basically you join
for free skip any month cancel anytime
and if you don't like the wine you don't
have to pay for it you just send it back
that's great I'm going to join that it's
a like I think yeah you guys got me on
that one nice all right thank you little
one thank you thank you thank you to our
sponsors for supporting the show if it
wasn't for them this wouldn't all be
possible so if you're in the market for
some wine some some tickets or trying to
look for a new fun game consider
supporting our sponsors thank you guys
thank you all right should we just keep
going or should we take a bathroom break
I could keep going
I'm good well I need to pee again okay
done we are gonna run to the bathroom
superfast actually my dad is here too I
want to say I don't know yeah they're
not yeah you arrived so please don't
leave something terrible will happen I
don't know what don't let anything
terrible happen like the longer you guys
stick around the better the base is
already perfect we don't want to mess up
just so you know we still have
conspiracy closet comment when you're
coming out I still I can you guys talk
about how was it a secret service funded
me Delos okay yeah yeah this was just
the beginning
not call about am i gay yo snoop I come
after me for this one never tell you
this he's put me down line rings can you
make sure that it comes here I want I
can just go to the [ __ ] bathroom I am
we have the news coming up we're just
getting yeah I'm wearing a diaper so I
mean I was just telling you guys I have
to pay I could Monica I'm cool I will be
back guys we're not going to I'm going
to literally run so we back in a short
man welcome back everybody to the Ashlee
podcast live hear what everybody who was
here before we were about to get into
the story of Jessie's music video with
Snoop Dogg were you guys kind of like
did a little meme where you assassinated
the president there was no assassination
it was a bit of a mean it was a bit of a
bigger story listen but a bit of an
assassination means notice that were and
which road is also off the set there was
this at the Park Row was it more like
because it was all about clowns and put
on imagery so like this one guy gets
shot by a cop and it's confetti but when
Snoop shoots Trump it's like a bang
fitting where you got to end the
universe not with a straight-up call for
assassins okay I'm kidding I'm kidding
so the Eternity up dead let's watch that
can we watch that that scene because a
sexual anyway the interesting part of
this story I mean I think most you guys
have seen it because it was it was quite
a big fiasco but um by Jessie rewrote
and they record the me right yeah right
so this what happen I was a TA shaadi
again oh my god okay alive screams with
EI and Snoop Dogg to play like
Battlefield or something and we have the
same manager so that's probably why we
got the same gig I get there I managed
oops there in the green room managers
like snoop
you should have jesse directly music
videos he wants to he's inspiring
director he wants to he's really good
students like for shizzle like whoa and
my managers even tell me was going to
say that to sue but he was just out of
nowhere I was alone and he's like stoop
you should also let Jesse post on his
channel I was like I love that idea
and snoops like yeah for sure
we played the video game the whole time
playing the video game snoop didn't like
the game too much because they went
little smoke pie in there in the whole
time he says will you let me smoke dope
I might like the game decided to fly and
then they gave me the controllers
inverted the whole time and they were
wondering why he was doing so that is I
didn't else they didn't know it's a I
watched that live by the way you saw her
yeah I loved it
oh yeah I love snoop coming up me and I
go we got the secret weapon and he's
next to zac efron or something and they
both I yeah does battlefield 1 yeah we
did without we have soup sitting next
with with the job ok another time gotcha
but yeah that was a great yeah so we're
even I'm like snoop let's go smoke one
in your van and talk about this video
he's like alright we go in his van and
we're smoking and umm and I'm basically
writing the idea for the video right
there as we're smoking weed and I'm like
yo it's around October and that's
whenever that clown mean was like a big
thing with killer clowns or reality they
were everywhere so we're gonna do
something like a clown universe with
like cops like in and talk about some
political [ __ ] and it was like when
Trump and Hillary were running cells
will clown them because they're both
clowns and woman will play on that and
we're going to put dog this on the other
cool is they I'll give you the song in
an hour I'll text it to us never on text
means to them like yeah this is crazy
this farts Snoop Dogg and I walk out the
van or I couldn't even find my uber and
then I go home and hear from for like
three days on my August it shouldn't
happen to like 6 o'clock in the morning
he sends me a text message a video of
him in studio writing the song and rapid
it he just made the song fresh song yeah
he's like I've made it a fresh one from
what you talked about in the bin like
Joe this is insane like oh my guys it
goes right to song for this time like
this is wow you co-wrote a song with
Snoop yes yeah counted and then uh they
send it to me like Kulak it to a
treatment and I'm like you know how
about this I'll put up half the money
you put up half the money and we'll put
on my channel and then you'll make your
money back from the song of sales
because I have a bigger following on
YouTube then than you do stupid weirdly
no foul so yeah no festive but but it
would it would just reform
perform better in whatever is a cool so
nobody like he was going to get like a
brand like a GoPro or something to give
us money I'm like no I don't want anyone
to tell us what we can't do because it's
very very controversy and I'm like so
it's just me and soup and management
nobody's involves just means to being
creative so I make the treatment I go to
his house I show him the treatment he's
like cool um it was just taking too long
to get the video done and and Donald
Trump actually won we're like whoa we
didn't like no one thought he was gonna
win and the night he we found out he
wants new calls and he's like yo he won
he can we were talking about Donald
Trump winning and he's like I'm like you
still want to make this video like now
it's just going to be about Trump he's
like yeah I don't care
we're gonna clown I'm like okay he's a
clown uh well you know fast word we get
the video done we shoot it edit it took
me like a month I worked super hard on I
did everything to producing or writing
directing um the finished products done
he loves it everyone loves it like some
some lawyers are like this is a little
you know which lawyers my lawyer was
like a long I'm sure Jesse and Mike I
mean it's not a legal raise it no it's
not a legal asperity it's you know it's
provocative yeah it's like you're on the
wine like a host Alliance freedom of
speech but it's I mean it is the sitting
president clown and it doesn't even get
fascinated it wasn't really like Kathy
Griffith love of that it wasn't it was
even close yeah with a straight parody
and it was a like a whole other universe
right I'm we're trying to get the story
short it's almost done now God like the
time it's great and then give us the
long version we put the video up and I
was up all night the night before the
final night of editing put it up the
next day he drops the song new and I go
to sleep because I was up all night I
just went right to sleep I wake up the
right-wing media is just destroying
Snoop Dogg did disgusting this is so
wrong TMZ I'm getting thousands of phone
calls from CNN
TMZ they all want to interview me snoop
calls me is like yard let's not talk to
anybody but the art speak for itself
don't talk to anybody and I'm like yeah
that's right I'm not going to go and see
anybody okay that's what made the video
kids were these the thing is if you put
your image in their hands they'll always
find a spinet so I'm like cool I just
denied all I had a publicist luckily at
the time and she's like grabbing
everything it was kind of negative at
the point like all the comments were
negative you're going to jail and other
Shani scared yeah the FBI is going to
come get you in all this [ __ ] in Weston
OOP angry I had I hadn't heard from
Snoop he hasn't said anything to me and
I'm like and I'm like oh [ __ ] and it's
like 24 hours of me just freaking out oh
my god did we just annoy handedly just
bring down Snoop Dogg's career can you
imagine like oh my god I'm gonna get
killed I thought I was gonna get killed
either by Snoop scared by like the
president right and I'm like sick I'm
like just like sick yeah manager that
connected us is sick he can't even talk
to me he's like thank God all his campus
pissed I go to sleep wake up the next
day Trump tweeted about it as soon as
Trump tweeted about it all left-wing
people are like these guys are heroes
this is a First Amendment this is not
too far he didn't actually get shot
because right-wing built it in a way
that looked like it was way worse than
it was you know the news name injustice
DOMA to dispel the whole context of it
we all know about that with PewDiePie
and uh and the left-wing was all like
this is great and it was all positive
and everyone celebrating soup dogs
texted me all the emojis so I got a
laugh whatever [ __ ] he's writing to me
because he loves the tweeting our text
emojis to me okay emojis like a fire gas
tank clown yeah I think that's it I
think I doing it was good and uh and
then and then her lawyer Supes lawyer
gets ahold of me says hey the Secret
Service wants to talk to you all right
so look [ __ ] now I'm sick again oh my
god [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and they're like
tomorrow I'm like cool these closet
ladies like okay we're not doing it
tomorrow we're doing it next week I'm
like what the [ __ ] I gotta wait a week
some stress for a week I'm turning my
phone off every time I talk to somebody
I'm just like thinking helicopters are
following me I run sure they're zeroing
in on yeah well you know Obama's got all
the drones so you were in that front and
it his lawyer was like you could go tell
them to go [ __ ] themselves and not meet
with them but no I'll find you really
yeah well you could you can just be like
hey Secret Service kinda
like well I feel like I'm not going to
the meeting I'm not going to meet with
you but they'll just come knock on my
door there Amen okay yeah I was like no
I'll meet with them whatever you were
yeah yeah and so we waited a week and I
remember and I haven't heard from suit
with the whole week we just worked quiet
so I don't know if he's mad at me I
don't know with know that yeah yeah so I
show up to the we're all meeting at
Stoops lawyer's office and I show up
snoop shows up he's [ __ ] demands dude
was the most humble awesome dude by the
way he's super nice and he's like yell
what's up Jesse everything's cool
everything's cool he was like super
mellow yeah and the lawyer was like
super excited on my client lawyer so
excited like I knew it yeah I think was
just excited because like we're making
history they're like yeah we're like
we're like making history right now I
mean how many rappers been interrogated
by the state and then the lawyer kept
joke I'm like is it illegal like am I
gonna go to jail he's like what inciting
violence on the president like you could
go to jail I'm like what are you saying
it's a bad answer
no pilot yeah what is unfair to you and
what are you talking about lawyers do it
where they'll be like I can't talk to
you like a real person because I gave
you the wrong reason then you can sue me
right so yeah there is a chance that you
can't go to prison for threatening the
life on the president dilma Mylene
insane into me like what the [ __ ] talk
to my lauren he's talked to guys that
were like freedom of speech big wig guys
and DC and said is completely not
illegal yeah
before I go forward like when it was all
going down TMZ loved to go up to rappers
and people in the streets there was all
these TMZ videos other than walking up
and showing the image of Snoop Dogg with
a gun and in the Donald clump right and
what do you think of this image and none
of the rappers or they all had stoop
Spectre all like it's art its art yeah
it's art and then what like I took like
ice-t watched it and he was like I
watched it it's not even bad and at the
end of the video can we with him
whatever
everyone had our back everyone
celebrities everyone was good um and
then I guess uh Madonna like a week
before said some crazy [ __ ] in the
Secret Service visited her so she says
I'm sure she say she was like at some
March and she had some things she was
going to set the way lane Harry
and so that's what my lawyer was like
listen she didn't go to jail they just
wouldn't visited her everything's been
fine all right so we're at the office
Secret Service shows up we're going to
like get explaining people it was uh it
looked like two ex-military guys to
Marcia and an older woman she was like
the boss we're at a table just like this
I'm here snoops here
I think snoops manager was in it and
snoops lawyer and me and we sit down
Secret Service sits down there like when
the one guy whoever here just started
speaking he was like okay we just wanted
to bring you in you know its protocol
for us and we don't want you to think
that you're in trouble in any way and
and the student sort of seemed real
nervous I'm a [ __ ] so nervous ugh
ya know like it's [ __ ] dog there's
rubber man in the [ __ ] machine just
like [ __ ] and by the way I'm like you
exam yeah going to resume just chillin
and then they are like yeah you didn't
do anything illegal it's just like our
duty if anybody ever says anything in
any way about the president we have to
just follow up or nice yeah it's
protocol and we just want to make sure
that you don't really want to harm the
president seems like nah man he's my
homie we are gross to them before on the
show and we're just having fun that's
true they did the Trump rusty it you
know I kinda mentioned Trump got so
butthurt after already spinning through
him well what did Trump tweeted Trump
tweeted if if Obama if Snoop Dog noises
with Snoop Dogg's dying career in all if
he would have put is the gun yeah if you
would have pointed the gun at Obama jail
time by the way I hate that it's not
true well I always hear this argument on
the left and right if if this was
Hillary good and then this would
happened can you imagine if Obama or
Hillary barely talked Parton like did
some crazy [ __ ] with some guns on stage
and yeah it's gonna shoot yeah I
remember that yeah so and I mean but
anyone go to jail I did it free that
over that but Ted Nugent but at just
that argument both sides odd that he
tweeted it because then the left people
found out about it and it is good and
then this one we've got millions of
views a little table he was on your side
after I almost think like stoop was like
Trump can you tweet about it
right now we're hating on me and if you
tweet about it we're gonna be all
balloting yeah luckily you it was just a
violence thing if you had done anything
about how he has a bunch of failing
businesses and [ __ ] hotel running he
would have really come after you I don't
think he saw the video Trump I think he
probably saw that image yeah he ran up a
good picture so anyway you're in the
media and then and then our minute ago
okay what was the meaning of the video
right and then I'm like well I'm like if
Snoop says the wrong thing maybe he'll
incriminate us and we might go to jail
and like he didn't write it I wrote it
so I don't know if he knows artistic
thoughts behind it and then he was like
he's about to speak and I'm like snoop
can I take it from here well the meaning
is that we want to kill the president
stop looking secret service on the
podcast [ __ ] not to kill them and my
god that was like you know it was like
it was a whole different universe it was
the play on the fact that I knew that
right-wing media was going to pick it up
and flip it way worse than it was right
and turn it into this thing and that's
just what I think is wrong with society
rights because like you see something on
the news but it's not really what
happened so like when the guy shot the
guy in the car in the music video all
you saw was him getting shot in the kids
Musa in the video that the kid filmed
but he had a gun and the in his suitcase
so it was a play on that's interesting
that I was wondering I was going to ask
you I was in yeah there was a play on
that like okay like that the Newt and
then it goes on the news on the TV and
the people riot it was like Ronald clump
was like the head of this riot going on
and he was supporting all dogs some of
you read it on the news just Ronald
clumps supporting all dogs it was
showing up at snoops house to deport him
and he pulls out a gun and the flag
comes out and we social commentary yes
that is so it was a and I knew that
image this image would it went viral and
it did and worked perfectly played right
into the of my thoughts on how turnout
so Trump saved your ass Somaly Mam saved
it that's [ __ ] to each other because
I remember when he tweeted it that
morning the video was going I've never
seen my real-time views do that before
whoa
yeah what a [ __ ] great story what I
finished and then we're telling that it
is like okay
The Secret Service look okay whose idea
was it right I look at snoops new books
in me we write me out and I'm like
looking around a lawyer as a manager and
like no one say they don't snitch I'm
like it was me it was me to go sit down
they wrote it I'm looking right over
here yeah laboratory efforts with Snoopy
Brazilian of course but yeah I wrote it
with base off Batman you know the Batman
see with the flag and then they're like
I really close the book on this we just
miss you they 100 president don't be
worried about freedom speech and let's
set up a report like you ever want to
lash out on the government maybe we
should talk and find out better web yeah
yeah I don't know about that
yeah that's cool that they said like you
know super yeah yeah then important
did we leave we walk down like snoop man
you gangster again now darling I know
and though then part two of The Hound
done yeah that is a great story from
getting Trump to tweet it to being
Integra gated by the Secret Service with
along Snoop Dogg I can only imagine when
the night a week that you had to wait
for that man oh I also wrote when Trump
tweeted I replied to him I said it's
just I just click baited you bro and
that you clicked and then super service
was like oh what's clickbait yeah
chicken and I had explained it to the
Secret Service and I'm like it's like
when Trump thought he saw him getting
yeah some way but it really wasn't
I clicked they didn't feel real smart in
that moment yeah that happened to us
when I was being deposed farthest or
being sued for copyright infringement
that his attorney asked me what does it
mean she says what does it mean because
he asked me fortunately it's just a
middleman I thought is like what is the
name you need to find a meme and I was
like oh my god so finally what a meme is
that acceptable to me me me Nate the
main a and I mean that as a kid in high
school I used to be a big prankster
oddly and I would prank the principal
I'd get in trouble I got kicked out of
high school and my brother like text me
your kids like you went from pranking
the principal to pranking the president
why did you do it yeah
only I don't know yeah there it is well
thanks for sharing that yeah all the
total party snoop well thank you care
anymore display is done well
did you want to watch it or just mm yeah
I mean here I'll show this world apart
ending just the part word like the part
where they and yeah and show the part at
the end we were smoking together to I
can text yeah so now in post when we're
in post I was like should we add the
gunshot and the muzzle flash or should
we just have it be late right and I kind
of regret the muzzle flash in the
gunshot yeah makes it a little more
violent you're right
I wish it was just like a cloud of smoke
and not a giant chunk yeah in fact you
know think that would it helped us a
little bit well you know we learned her
but truly if you compared to like what
Kathy Griffith did when I look at that
image that was just anger I'm just like
what it was the social commentaries that
was not necessary or any budding it was
no message there was just girl you got
real mad on a Tuesday and was like we
know I think it was I think it was the
the photographer was like Kathy Snoop
did this and it worked wonders for him
and maybe you should be separated and
everybody's gonna love it that's that's
probably not you know exactly how it
goes up I'ma be trending what a tolerant
let whoops where's our sisters house you
see took it hard and she took a real
hard real trouble we did about her she's
a different claim used to went to the
line and kind of like tiptoed around the
line a little bit
she likes jump over the line and I took
a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah she moved all
right well we've got two more segments
coming up we've got here was contingency
corner yeah by the way when you were
talking about snoop it was for 20 no I
didn't want to break your alright and I
will just want us to get super high for
the conspiracy segments no my mom texted
me she said Ethan tiny houses are all
the rage because you can tow them like
trailers she says where what so wherever
you go your home comes with you she said
all the rage she said Ethan the tiny
houses are all the rage because you can
tell you I sure
shipping containers right you're talking
about a glorified trailer home I'm sorry
I still hate it and those houses we saw
are not trailer bull it looked like IKEA
showroom stuffed in depression creators
anyway you need it you know join it both
need a big-ass boat yeah if you're
trying to with the trade route you're
all right Eric it's time for your is it
conspiracy my Agha and dreams you guys
want to get salty I mean you know I can
probably grab a bud if you want to be
here some you want a coffee
um little water you go sir I am the
wider my third eye is really hone in on
stuff but I do have this all cued up I'm
ready to go I'm gonna grab a bud yeah
I'm gonna grab Ryan can you bring us
some buds
bring the buds you wanted my needle bud
we need to but it up do you want to be
real yes three years global Satan was a
fool liver and so guys uh now we hand it
on over to Eric once we get those butts
yeah what we do have an intro that's
about to play yeah oh yeah a cue from
Dan some oh I'm just going to wait till
it plays on this thing oh wait wait
you're telling on it
oh wait I got to switch the thing so do
you have because I'm hooked up to the
month yeah you get it we got to hook me
you gotta hook up help us yeah don't
play the intro yet reducers on it I'm
not credit for the conspiracy oh yeah I
was supposed to call so Flo all right
let's do that you know okay do that
while you this is such a show of such a
[ __ ] no we're good to mimic that's
casual that will agree no it's a bag you
got a cause for low so well you get this
or visit I would hire know Jesse drink a
beer with I think that I'm gonna appeal
of a podcast really poppy bud yes all
right don't have it oh wait what you
have the other day was like I went to
the 4:20 where you want can we do that
again up mm-hmm
this Joe Rogan is on camera no it does
it off camera do what wait I thought we
can get demonetized
there a mind nothing we're not talking
about anything you can go while we you
guys want to take a bath alone you guys
go take a quick break yeah there's
there's Bud Light out in the lobby
yeah yeah all right so while those guys
go get their Bud Light
I'm gonna call Soflo um
socio flow yeah yeah give them the
background filament little accident this
this is great I love the show man from
Secret Service is calling so far about
his spam hold on here I'm telling okay
so so flow on his channel on YouTube he
hasn't posted in like months maybe a
year I don't even know and then all of a
sudden a week ago or two weeks ago he
posted 500 videos in one day mm-hmm I
don't even know how it's possible was
just a bunch of spammy crap he posed 500
video he posted a million yeah like his
whole video tab is full of videos that
he uploaded in one day Jesus so let's
see if he answers because there's a good
chance that and doesn't remember him I
had scheduled it with him so we want to
ask him what is the strategy behind it
because it seems my high level YouTube
yeah I want to get in on there and
analysis level you know there's clearly
some high level six offal as a smart guy
he's a savvy businessman he's a shark is
he's a shark but when I saw those 500
videos upload I'm like so Flo for those
reasons I'm out in a little toasted
right now I know what happened you just
texted him yeah I text him you don't
want to surprise him with a call well no
I we talked about earlier in the week
and I said hey so Flo can I call you on
Friday and he said yeah just text me
ahead of time so we scheduled a goal at
408 kind of missed our time he's in
Hawaii he's on vacation in Hawaii uh-oh
he's such a G he was going to take this
call he's on vacation so okay so we can
hit him up so flow a long time ago did
you what was your impression of him Eric
can you set up it was flirting meantime
he was literally vidcon thirsty for what
oh sorry Dan I might need a little eyes
collaboration this and then he like
figured out some Facebook thing somebody
was like doing YouTube I think my middle
yeah he was doing prank that guy is like
I'll say I always say this about the
pranksters those guys hostile like no
one else
guy went from doing YouTube pranks yeah
you having one of the biggest Facebook
you know because of the prank community
as a youtuber was like it was like the
low-hanging fruit for [ __ ] boys yeah
yeah definitely
well you were doing you were in the
prank game but I wasn't doing the public
[ __ ] that was like a whole different
beast in its own when I was like this
weird [ __ ] where I was just [ __ ]
around my girlfriend right and and there
was like one other channel that did it
at the same time that was like just kind
of riding that wave with me right kind
of hated him
I [ __ ] love the channel name the name
was called uh but what's the name of the
channel I just know them they're Nikki
and John [ __ ] those guys man over there
no no but like for the longest day they
would always tried say we copied them
but we we were way ahead to them but
like my channel got deleted
why because I when I first started the
internet videos uploaded on break calm
and like if you could on break calm you
get two hundred bucks on school I dared
my girlfriend eat cinnamon she ate it
choked I put it on the internet I got
two hundred dollars all in the military
at a time I like break just pays you
$200 to upload a video there know if it
hits their home page big thick it's
funny enough for their home that's
interesting but what I didn't know is
they're taking the full exclude latex I
get the right it or the whole right I
didn't know I just signed my money I was
Mike that I needed that like five times
and then I went to youtube and put those
two videos on YouTube and it started
creating buzz and then they did DC MV
whatever what no it took my channel down
and I had to start over again was a
blessing in disguise
yeah because my name was like Jesse
welly Jesse has the YouTube channel then
I started over in progress right but now
it's back to Jesse so did you cut out
the well ago wow man this license holder
really take advantage of people same
with these companies claps like what so
flow does not ready lies the legends to
videos yeah
actually no he just upload them who's
just riddled on the license is secondary
is there oh you caught me wait signed
this there's 200 bucks I don't have
forever there's these companies like uh
what are these big ones called jump
giant comedia
chunkin' they'll still go find a viral
video be like I'll give you $25 they lie
I very own like all like 90% on
everybody oh yes it's it's in crime not
gonna say fast people clown on me that I
always say that's fascinating in every
episode as if it's a problem to be
fascinated fascinated by JIT are we not
here to fascinate and be fascinated it's
like the [ __ ] B version of glass are
you not fascinated are you not
fascinated
there's a suggestion to call solids
about his latest video I'm not I
absolute yeah he made like Joey such a
[ __ ] character this guy's makes a
classic salads video something oh yeah I
remember he went to outside Jake Paul's
house and he's like look how easy I can
have abduct his fan did a child
abductions I got a gigolo and then he
text me even before I watch it soon as
he posted he says yo Ethan watch my new
video it's cancer and I'm like I can't
react to your video now there's like yes
where Jesse he's trying to win with it
yeah yeah I think his business card just
says Joseph salads child abductor yeah
at this point just a kingdom hands over
big like 90% obviously and jail goes
when we have him on a show he's like I'm
not going to tell you what should my
pranks are fake but I'll tell you 99.99%
of all pranks are fake on internet I'll
exit okay so that leaves about maybe
like one have you ever met him yeah you
met without man I'm Excel it's probably
playlist live over some solid yeah he's
willing to embrace it he's on ice yeah
he doesn't [ __ ] around well I mean he
does but he's honest about it which
right let's get he's a typical Jersey
Guido in my school died one more push is
Dickon hotdog button you seen that
whoops no I've kissed his mouth
oh yeah there's like a whole bunch of
them he was doing this thing for girls
on you know we go into the yeah it said
that he shot it for a movie like a
jackass no he apparently they had a
snapchat account another effort they
made a lot of noise following Joey
Saldana
a bunch of gay guys they did it back in
the day he was putting his dick and a
hotdog bun and putting on snapchat and
you got like a huge gay following
I'm a tip of the be room yeah yeah I
mean gate you know I mean hey it's nice
to be desired by somebody right hey so
solid high security okay
he'll did tilt he'll he'll dispute that
but I suspect Joey is alone well now he
has a girlfriend and they have like a
cylinder now he's in LA are you guys
ready step right up he's gay speaking of
but you want it doesn't admit it this
salad I love it we're like he's gay he
won't admit it but hot hotdog buns are
male is doing kind of like my boyfriend
oh he put all his money in this
girlfriend yeah and when he was here I
told him I thought you a relationship is
favori one day John wall's
he's pranking Rick 2017 Lance dude it's
real everybody wants it it's not work
are we ready okay we problem you know
that we want our Joey conspiracy but we
really pranks each other that was the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] we really wouldn't know I
believe I believe you I I honestly
tipped my way to Yahweh's oh wait you
fake some stuff I'll meet her meet her
no it was never like hey honor sharing
your day yeah it was like this was
always surprising it was like this I'd
walk into a situation it would be off
and I'm like up uh hold on okay or
something here okay not gonna spoil it
okay
but I see she spent the time to try and
get angry right now okay
spying my food [ __ ] doing my food it's
going to be oh so you have my ah it's
probably the food I'm looking for a kid
like you watch some of my videos like
I'm looking for cameras if I said she
was pregnant once
that was [ __ ] 100% real and I really
believe that oh my god oh and I look
around and I look and you see me looking
for the camera cuz I'm like this is a
prank
oh [ __ ] not a bank I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm
having a baby
oh [ __ ] oh so I got out and then she's
like pranked yeah yeah and I'm like wait
what wait what the Frank and what is
really pertinent Oh
it was the [ __ ] up thing is she would
she was smart though she was really good
she would put plant the seed like she
would be like three weeks you like why
I'm coming
oh but that live it on camera so I like
see right slant the seem to be like
three seriously well guess what I took
the test me of course really hardly did
I'm like you do without me that's a
rotten could see like legitimately did
you guys have like a safe word no it
means every time that would be like the
first thing that we would always go hey
right now that thing other people do it
like they're usually telling me not to
do bugs and I would do bugs all the time
oh yeah she's like listen don't do buses
and you'll see some videos up or bug out
she's like [ __ ] you you're not posting
there my god or like there was a safe
word it was like we would get naked
right away so that we know we couldn't
be saw what a life there was drunk
oh but like yeah like so was never fake
it was more of like be a food one maybe
like she like put some spicy [ __ ] in a
burrito on me and I sat down and I could
just sense it I was like [ __ ] is
inviting me in the food or something
whatever it is and I [ __ ] it and then I
realized I'm like [ __ ] it's that spicy
[ __ ] would that ever happen but there
was no prank all the time so you're like
in your head all times
yeah there's almost like a parent like
you're almost having paranoid delusion
right and we had a really obsession of
[ __ ] with each other when the other
person would fall asleep especially on
the couch and it really kind of [ __ ]
me up likes my sleeping like it would
really [ __ ] me up and if you watch it
if you want to see a really funny video
of a prank that's 100% real I'm sleeping
and she wakes me up this one that breaks
[ __ ] bones probably you want to watch
and I snap into sleepwalking mode and I
like scream like bloody murder and try
to hide behind her and it's funny it's
really fun what has about you if you
just google I don't even know how to
find it um baby going on YouTube and
search like boyfriend
prank vs. prank sleeping all right let's
get it [ __ ] I don't know let's get into
you're just rude
next time I'm gonna I'm just putting
into my to do list for for next time I'm
gonna all right well listen the longest
break ever
alright thanks for taking around
everybody up to the bottom of it okay
okay are we ready I think we're ready
you guys ready I am preparing to play at
any second and then we'll get into it
I'm just watching myself and it's like
half a second off it's very bizarre Hey
alright guys welcome to the conspiracy
closet you already jump into the closet
with me
let's take a leap listen I went deep I
went deep this time I found I found a
conspiracy that I think that everybody
can get on the same page about cool I'm
talking about of course celebrity clones
mmm you guys heard about celebrity
clones at all is this something not
really very well then you're in for a
treat because I thought this one was
really great I've compiled three cases
that I believe to be the strongest
evidence that the shadow masters who run
our civilization are taking our most
beloved celebrities cloning them and
then sending them right back out as
brainwashed real hold on what did you
feel with the original wait I have heard
of this do you realize I they just say
that they throw yeah you're like yes one
is Lord hater yeah yeah I mean Michael
Jackson Michael that's one of the ones
that came across he's perished the
colones has paired yeah his clones dead
oh so you can't clone the clone is it
like when bolon perishes what I found is
that they just have kind of like stem
cells on record okay okay
for most celebrities so they just keep
the stem cells and if that celebrity
dies but the Illuminati and the shadow
masters want to continue some sort of
dialogue with them to help them like
right get people in line and everything
clone so we could have a Michael Jackson
return at any moment yeah now when
tipped me off was actually this article
right here from the Metro can you folks
grant yeah I think so hang on I'm still
this is
the one thing that I haven't gotten
there we go okay this is a first of all
what happened to Avril Lavigne
conspiracy theory that the singer is
dead life is back again now I was like
what is that I was going to get you by
that headline it kind of all depart
grammatically
at the end of their material by the way
news but not as you know it it's just
pretty oh you know it's cool you know
it's going to be that right news
we're news but not as you know it Wow
they also have their shares at the top
right so they're taking the keemstar
model of just telling you how much be it
22 million oh why did I sentence that's
not like me more like a lot that's that
didn't seem like a lot of like all of
their article yeah that's good be like
anyone ever share a metro articles
article by Avril Lavigne but this
article I'm interesting details why does
the sentence say yeah cannot be really
that the singer is dead life is back
again
that was somebody I think that about a
trauma yeah their headline written if I
were to I think conspiracy theories in
here is dead mama bears bag lightest
words that my wife because this was an
old theory that Avril Lavigne had died
okay and was replaced well convinced me
well here's here's a piece from the
article right here started by a
Brazilian Avril Lavigne fan page the
idea goes that after the release of her
2002 debut album Avril couldn't handle
the pressures of Fame and began using a
body double called Melissa called
Melissa
here's a picture with Melissa on her
fist yeah hence the picture shortly
after beginning work on her second album
the page claims it Avril fell into
depression and was later found dead at
her home by her record company who just
I mean you've talked to Snoopy probably
told you all the time like yeah man the
record company just comes in check
something
yeah should the company began using Lola
as the real Avril who then apparently
begins leaking details of Averill's
death via song lyrics I have a question
album booklets if this was a massive
conspiracy why would they have a picture
of her reg Melissa on her fist oh would
I drop that you know that's a good
question and I think that it can boil
down to like if they do that it suddenly
makes the conspiracy like redic
to dairies oh it's at we're getting
ahead of doing a 180 on they know us
better than we know ourselves so I did
some ELISA and her song lyrics like that
I'm not sure if that is Melissa or if
she just wrote Melissa on her hand say
like this is my best friend who's acting
like the climbs as a clone yeah well no
no no this is not a case of clones I'm
like leaning into it with you guys like
I'm getting real soft into it like what
it gets into the clone thing who's
Melissa she's not a Clovis is not clone
she's just a ivory Levine's friend just
not but I happened to look like her okay
and then when Avril Lavigne died in 2003
they replaced her with this elusive
Melissa character and suddenly got a
look all of a sudden her banging friend
looks identifing our difference as you
can see well luckily the resolution is
high enough photos make a joke what's
their friends yeah let's go how you told
me I don't know this one has a herpe
outbreak you know it's tough because
like they're very good at making someone
look like the other person but there's
small things that they can't change like
if you notice the eyes on the right a
little bit bigger that's not what the
circles okay yeah I don't know who draw
those circles but yeah that's this
makeup I think they're trying to say the
gutter for every person that is the same
Pro this is not yeah that's the same
purse that's what they want you to
believe it everybody really look into it
when I think there are there are
differences I mean here hang on let's
see what we got here
there you see well let me see if I can
zoom in without their dad is a retired
pane now we'll explain the missing
freckles we're just going so didn't they
have them no way what about the hon have
disproved them so that's one two three
together right ed yeah well that's a
young with such an easy response go okay
no way they did that they did this but
these are the Brazilians but I see it's
in like everybody's they have their own
ideas about de estilo it says at the
bottom of the question mark so you had
the other ones removed
yeah I wasn't sure if this was actually
pointing out freckles or not because I
can't pretend I care about the other
body is resilient
yeah did you know yeah okay I think this
one was a pretty interesting look into
the idea of celeb reading and getting
replaced keep that keep them on edge
going the money the money are the
message I think it's the money in the
message man you know it's also like you
got to get her parents money the message
to the memes and then all of a sudden
this replacement starts making songs
with like song lyrics hinting at it like
you guys remember Avril Lavigne said my
name is actually Melissa it's off the
album my parents are totally cool with
naturally name being dead I didn't catch
that one it's a good outfit listen to
whatever really under the radar it's on
Spotify what else I really got that wait
we got in Fox
okay wait before you move on that
article is from this year right yes that
was from May of this year I think that's
really important to me oh yeah that
would be the one that like you know if
anybody following along at home I think
that that would be the one if they're
like oh yeah no remember I'm looking at
these pictures of what's your name
that's Megan Fox now we had this vision
of Megan Fox and what I'm seeing is
somebody aging seven years with blindly
clear exactly as it would seem right but
with what in fact is happening here is
multiple cloning I don't know what the
hell went wrong with her but the theory
on mailbox luck is this [ __ ] for real
tea I think she was like made in America
like she didn't have like the Japanese
like they make [ __ ] right they actually
last long enough the Japanese American
you got a reboot they look for real yeah
man yeah okay so in this case they're
saying she's been cloned four times I'm
with it I found a whole YouTube video
actually that's just titled Illuminati
clones was megan fox replaced and i'd
love to play for you guys that's okay
why would they give her such ugly thumbs
done ugly thumb well you got to keep it
you didn't know she was ugly stones
lunar thumbs are shaped like shovels
that's like the idea no with her like oh
he's beautiful she's perfect but have
you seen your thumbs
it is I would've liked that alright guys
now this is a video that should prove
without a doubt the Megan Fox was clones
okay what's with the right cheek clones
well subscribe as you can see there's no
I think well I recorded this I might
have realized that that was annoying his
[ __ ] and did something about it
come on past Eric can I just take
animals can I take them okay I got it
thank you
yeah just reflect on life what's with
plastic surgery what do you mean there's
a Columbian that's just okay let's
pretend for a moment who don't want the
be young forever but it like she how old
is she she's like in her 20s she's
putting [ __ ] poison in her face she
probably look amazing I mean make she
looks good still but what do you think
she got lip injections she's got cheek
she lips every forehead she's all over
the place but they're all black in
plastic surgery very much Botox yeah
both I'm pretty sure when they clone you
they don't make you look a little bit
better every time
like she glitched out malfunctions you
guys know that clones can glitch that no
I can't like to see oh my god I thought
my phone was me the the most interesting
item oh no my clone I thought i muted
myself was ready for a call
Oh God let's do that George yeah let's
do hang on [ __ ] so Flo time for you
right now miss sorry so I do my segment
a self loan that's actually connections
you yeah they're not gonna release your
investigation your clone yeah I think
you do because you you're also
conditioned to to like put your
propaganda out there to to be a clone
and there's a did you know there's a
reason that you are a clone because the
person who you're cloned from didn't do
the job right right shot of masters came
in took them out in the sleep clone in a
bed immediately just wake up ARMA clone
they're like clone next time you make a
Transformers movie make sure it's good
it's like in West world the show West
roble those they didn't know that they
were manufactured beings until that's
what the comment broke their conditions
so the clones don't know right so I'm
dark and
the clones out there you got to break
your conditioning guys and I it's crazy
how much proof there is about this like
if you've never seen a clone glitch out
before you might not even know what it
looks like but let me show you
you guys know al Roker's a clone I
didn't know that snooze to me it's kind
of weird right that is weird
did he lose weight but the clone that
they cloned him skinny take club Kevin I
think oh he lost the weight himself he
was on a personal crusade to lose all
those that weight and then they're like
you're dead bring in the club they were
like we don't like the way you're acting
I put you in the clone booth you ever
seen someone lose so much weight you're
like he looks better fat no people are
gonna say that about me when I love it
you know I resolved photo Jonah Hill
right
I was it wrong yeah it looks pretty good
my bad nice yeah we thing I I'm telling
you Domino like uh Jared from Subway he
[ __ ] kids oh yeah he was definitely
better fat before he was [ __ ] all it
was it the kids to need him lean I think
it might have been was all the fun got
skinny Joe doll gets lucky and he was
like I'm skinny now and to play the
field kind of like on the kid
transitional rocker so keep an eye on Al
keep an eye on oh this guy's a clone
he's about the glitch the [ __ ] out the
other toe on the right might also be
clones like the West Show today Oh
rightly so if you is right again it
should constrict there's a pretty little
thing way holy God everybody in the chat
adjusts awfully good you like went into
a trance it was like this trigger word
yeah she she word again
okay I see it again which is look a
whole round off and just play okay look
Oliver I alternate explanation I think
you may have had a stroke well close can
obstruct through turns the Holy Ghost
did somebody say Holy Ghost assassinated
all right that's what I told you
looking at the producer right now like
yeah what'd you tell her to say that
some of us got in his ear and said some
nasty to him but why is he working so
hard and so long like it's so
inappropriate like television and this
video electical this is the best clip I
could find out it favors out before he's
done I want you to snap out be like yeah
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
see her they see that I'm a clone it is
like a sci-fi movies were there like
cupcake penguin and then you're like I
have to Sasson ate JFK yes like The
Manchurian Candidate kind of thing are
you gonna watch it again
I'll get back at you guys want to see
Johnny Depp glitching out yeah yeah oh
johnny densify oakland wants it okay
well here's some hot it's conspiracy
goes I believe that's lista there's just
a drunk
he's also bit of a lunatic yeah well
yeah you might be right about know me
think that tell you what's it we got
Johnny Depp completely sober and then
out of a bar Oh his body slams come on
what was that
what um I'm gonna I'm going to play that
again which I'd like you guys to take
note of it what the audio is that around
him says and the music going I need
again there's a lot going on in this
video very little okay this guy's really
close to them Oh like I grab Johnny what
would you do to Johnny did his body slam
or did you guys not Johnny with the head
that's on top of them that's somebody
else well I mean no one's Johnny in this
is there he's a clone oh hey what
happened here okay I was a hat like
waterfall I think some yeah someone hug
them and then they fall yeah I fall boys
laugh poor Johnny he's drunk I think
he's just a fresh out the cloning booth
you know I got me a lamb legs so that
the language I'm due tackled him I don't
think they tackled him I think they
hugged him he was just a little bit he's
gonna lose on the legs can you imagine
how I am and he just like oh and then
the reaction would you right yeah yeah
listen to what this [ __ ] guy says
right afterwards you like lamb vanish
in my huge augur Johnny
he doesn't say yell at posit he does
have a bit of a weekend with Bernie
vibrant yeah yeah that's a good dead
version yeah if that movie was Manny
2017 they just would have taken his stem
cells and cloned them in you what Bernie
would have walked tonight would you do
to Chara guys like wasn't me bro he's
backed aside here's a quote this program
funny yeah he just knocked like a cell
phone out of some dudes hand there thank
you that was a riot it's pandemonium
outside this place watch this guy right
here
[ __ ] you what happened like go back go
back you like smack something that is
really got mad [ __ ] watch what you're
doing there right here boom don't touch
me five is why the guy did not Johnny
over humble him into the car now
yeah like this is wait I think that was
his home
like look he's still like yeah I just
tackled you why would you do it him
because when you talk to you he's moving
over the guys getting in the car soon I
forgot it to level he's that I got it
knocked him over he's the clone master
all right oh and by the way this one was
gonna analyze this oh holy [ __ ] she's
she's with me she's from Tree Hearts
Church mm-hmm
look at this smug so I would like to
share where's her tactic what is Jesus
at the office which was Kyle Roker good
question I had prepared for that
question you at the crate all right I
can't listen this dummied program what
their experience
yeah I can none he's never had them and
he doesn't have them now oh this this is
another clone malfunctioning you can see
me kind of searching through the YouTube
video I just make sure you guys have
liked all the proof you need so we can
really get down to brass tacks we'll
discuss so would you say I'm a clone
because of my e3 performance now you put
yeah yeah bad teleprompter it was my
clone
malfunction okay that was the clone I'm
back he plugged uh you guys ever see
this clip no but I love the jury's out
on this one like you know I believe in
clones I think the clones are like
really shitty clip beside the Jersey
yeah as yours out on this one this might
just be okay are you okay you wanna hang
on NASA no okay Oh JIT what's about the
[ __ ] okay go on
okay okay
Mason not I can't shake this music I
think it's happening off screen they
just know the clone open please wow so
that guy was a [ __ ] blaze but this
man genetic proof clone handshake was
brought to you by the blaze oh this is
Eminem trolling right I know but this
one is what really got me like this I
feel like my whole segment right now is
built around this clip just watch this
and tell me this is better than Al Roker
it's better this is proof look at that
man's eyes keep an eye on it yeah what
whoa oh little sound effects wait wait
go back go the [ __ ] back well I got a
zoom Zin ready okay good I'm glad you're
prepared get your focus straight dum-dum
what what Damon is tell me that man
don't have the clone on I think it's
like reptilian Lamaze alone is is also
estádio just kind of quit any coding
problem yeah well you know the eyes
I've seen that don't hear Justin Bieber
interview too or maybe he's a clone I'm
just a beer tell me just viewers and now
we're going in alone we might be getting
in if anyone's gonna be one attempt
desolate
like long day we did they shed what the
hell that wasn't supposed to be recorded
that's my bad
we should probably go to the next video
so that was the second place over here
she's like I got to leave this comment
regardless I just wanted to let him know
I was there I thought I'm still thinking
about the first video which one I want
the guy who just like stares at the
camera I'll run her that are the
weirdest one yeah yeah we had a stroke
if I had again well that would be the
Illuminati getting in your head and you
know those are just the first two cases
like I just wanted to build a bit of a
like a foundation so that I could really
just really get in and there's a lot of
ways to spot a clone like for one you
could open up their skull and see if
there's a barcode oh that's a little
extreme we're not recommending anyone do
it I wouldn't do that unless you have
their possession yeah yeah you could
test their blood and by the way if they
a clone is programmed to not want to
give its blood up to strangers interest
obviously part of the AI program where
you could ask them and they would make
sarcastic jokes about it and that's a
that's also programmed the clones are
programmed to make sarcastic jokes where
they're like oh yeah I'm a clone they do
that part of the programming I think
footage of that no I don't uh I was
trying to find some I was hoping maybe I
could get some later
I'm going to go camp out some houses and
get some footage okay good it's this
third case that really and I don't know
why I never noticed this before but I
have reason to believe that Ethan and
Gila from h3h3 productions are related
into that clones [ __ ] you know you
approve this [ __ ] yeah obviously I saw
the first vector I don't know what that
was
oh is that a soundboard oh it's the it's
the inception thing they come in we need
more
on board dan okay all right on the dad
this is you guys right now okay really I
just want to make that clear this is
what you guys look like oh yeah that was
like take Kevin our datagrams we're days
ago okay that's perfectly framed and
lumens let me take you back to 2003
staying with the blue this is what you
guys look like about 14 years ago the
differences aren't obvious hold on
that's a video for my three months ago
no simple wedding refuse your Illuminati
lies I love the gay way Dan you ready
you ready with the sound effect three
two one love is just go why did you
change the hate wears a hat from hate to
love I have changed [ __ ] weight even is
amazing I got this little bitty baby Oh
God
what is it clone have a [ __ ] gold
tooth um what are you talking about
before you mean your original that's
right let me get my [ __ ] neck hair
all the way down
you're also Wolfman listen I'm just
asking questions here guys okay
my third ask question I find the true
though here's you dancing your way out
of the corn center this this might be
Photoshop I don't I don't know for sure
but Jesse you're not safe either buddy
oh oh no an enemy I'm a clone house you
a week ago look here this guy beat the
[ __ ] out of attacking Canadian robot
yeah that's pretty here chatter day
that's like this yeah that's carding
going on ed Bassmaster and we had a kid
named testy juniors I you're the kid
yeah Eric obviously we're clones ha ha
ha ha
really fun what very funny in conclusion
I guess what actually are there any
other youtubers you guys think might be
clones Eric yeah all right well let me
show you the next one that's a good
guess and nope it's PewDiePie is that
really bean use Avril Lavigne
Olivia Narayana all this reckless
missing I was like oh that's doesn't
like peopIe a little bit in other - guy
from Aerosmith oh do you know what I
don't know what gender that is 2017 I'd
rub my shaving all over that yeah it's a
shame that we lost that too rare to live
too beautiful to die or did I say it
backwards let's go back up to this one
I hate helenseims that's ours we head
doing the ugly face Jessie explain this
know what's what's going on here man
who is this alright and but uh I mean I
just wanted to bring it to your
attention guys because you invited me
onto this show and as I dig deeper and
deeper I'm starting to find out that
maybe I'm in bed with the devil
thanks for stepping into the closet guys
you see what the devil thank you bed is
comfortable
he's [ __ ] good yeah he smells good
tell me all about it all right thank you
lay any racks up in foil okay to wrap up
the segment to wrap it up can we watch
that video again oh they all look at you
hang on this is good for the highway I
won't feel like I'm too drunk off this
so flow no wrap it up I have to wrap it
off dude do it do a wiper if you don't
want to mess up that hair hat we need
you to sip it again
yeah I forgot I didn't have it written
in my generator yarmulke okay so what
I'd like in my life is to buy a um cargo
a cargo ship house and in foil to the
guarantees that I'll be cooked alive all
right um you look like a chimney
you guys can edit this into the
beginning of the segment right yeah
we'll tape in the part we'll take care
of that nice nobody watch this he can
arrest you guys okay
then nobody watches time to move on to
the news I gotta move yeah I do I do
want to watch oh yeah you want your
rocker again yeah I mean what the [ __ ]
like what actually happened here are
there someone in the zeros like I'm
crazy the that's it that's kind of a
good guess alright playe yeah it's like
allows your fire he's like how you look
better fat there is a lot of memories
did somebody said some [ __ ] is here in
his like [ __ ] 35 years ago today Elvis
Presley passed away the king of
rock'n'roll is Marco Elvis Presley and
he went on walking in there's a pretty
little thing waiting but it came down to
what why I'll just realized like you
left the iron on or something yeah
Linder so long I make using the car
shiver here I just get my business I
seems like cooler if you [ __ ] your pants
well can I get you guys word that you'll
break your conditioning and not let the
Illuminati control what you put out
there I mean as far as I know I'm not a
clone so I'm not sure that there's
anything I have to know don't know no it
would take a while to do it I'm I mean
yes yes I promise to break my rendition
thank you thank you guys and my mission
is now complete I like the tin foil
yarmulke under the guise we're under the
eyes of God we are all equal got you
Eric thank you guys for starry no thank
you Eric's closet
what a wonderful segment thank you for
presenting that you really changed my
worldview yeah everything I mean
absolutely I'm only here to get artists
look absolutely not just want to whistle
did I'll tell you now I just can't get
that thought of PewDiePie ever leaned
out of my head oh yeah you might see
anything shows for you again then I got
it we got to move on okay so coming up
next we have the news I'm going to go
run to the bathroom we will be back in a
short short break stay tuned welcome
back everybody to the H Street podcast
we have our final segment here with your
boy Dan let's do the so Flo call next
week right you want do it now we have so
Flo possibly on the phone you uploaded
500 videos to his channel I'm very
curious why okay let's give a call
before
possibly [ __ ] today people demand it
alright let's go was it fun if I'm in a
video it's got to be like average
negawatt per video
hairlessness gets along this hey so flow
with subject how are you I'm good man
I'm looking at a flight from Kauai to
Honolulu
nice so you're in Hawaii you're on
vacation you took the call you're live
right now by the way
so are we talking about new meeting up
with Dean decent so yeah I'm not being
yeah he finally reached out but we
didn't have time to meet up with him
because it was too last-minute although
I wanted to ask you about something else
about thumbnail no I wanted to ask you
about on your YouTube channel so flow I
noticed that you had uploaded 500 videos
in one day oh yeah I'm nicer than public
Hall because like I probably them a long
time ago but I decided might as well
just take them off for look just get the
views that's like a thousand two
thousand dollars a month it's like not
much really to be honest but why not
only lashem not because there's some
[ __ ] up doing them all with all them are
inappropriate you know how at the ads
don't like like the ad the ad buyers
won't like that and I forget stuff on on
a whole week so you just had a bunch of
private adore unlisted videos and you
just public them all exact worth -
sounds like a [ __ ] phone are you
falling on line know what I what oh
sorry
um so you may like a couple thousand
bucks from that probably not like as
afar like a couple hundred I'm just
saying like a crispy like a thousand two
dollars a month I like the first few
months something about 50 so you're at
this point you're just like [ __ ] this
channel I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
grab the news that I can get a scare
about 600 1:01 if anyone wants to buy it
you guys can put some offers on how much
word yeah how much would you sell your
YouTube channel for cuz Eric over here
is rhythm I'm rapper I got the checkbook
in my hand so slow seriously how much
absolute for the month I was money he
made on all my
just on one point a fella what yeah I
mean I want I just want the so flow
channel not the whole brand black ray
tube channel flat rate I buy it
gently this is one with 1.89 right so
like you want 1.5 million for that no no
say has 1.8 million subscribers okay
yeah yeah but yeah but you just posted
five hundred videos and they each have
like a thousand views I know I want me
to obviously it like they all get posed
at the same time you know hottest I mean
even now in any channel so what is it
will have you know a couple hundred K
couple hundred K you should be worth a
lot more than that but I'd probably be
willing to settle for up more than
decent prices I don't get in them yeah
clone them and get them to do it all
over here we're going to talk amongst us
we're going to see what kind of offer we
can put together for you as Memphis stem
cells are on record we're going to get
back to you next week and then what we
could find our silver back for that
journal generally well enjoy a try and
piss off bro bro yeah I'm gonna I do
how amazing would that be jesse wellens
is here he's our waiter he's willing to
offer you his hundred thousand K plaque
for your channels at us you didn't think
oh alright man thanks for taking the
call hope you have a great holiday
that's so gangster that you call us when
you're on vacation and white TV and make
sure you let me know let me let me know
if you get you think to go on the same
I'll go with them Oh character he's a
good guy Debian meme heaven well let's
get you on the phone newsmen don't bring
in the food yes are you serious dude he
said he said he said if I don't have one
at maybe even has one I got you room
I'll buy one for him we have a bug all
right I just hung key on my grave I
gotta go clean up a ball no save it
Roger message thanks thanks did talk to
you by black colleges to my pants I
don't think that guy's my clone actually
another thing about it he's too original
they would have improved the version by
now
all right you guys all right I called
self law however find out that um Ethan
Bradberry was doing this spider-man
videos well in the very beginning they
made a fatal flaw okay
they had a channel called mo any ammo in
Haiti their second Channel and they
converted it into a spider-man Elsa
Channel it only had five thousand subs
at a time but if you went to Google+ you
would see the URL still said mo and et
who did that investigator you know
somehow now I say someone else I knew
about them doing that a long time ago
somebody told me they're like oh this is
Mel once I was a look at the views is
getting she was like there's two guys
the other channel called the prank
channel they had that was I was mowin ET
Octavia Octavia doc TV guys doing this
whole zero why he was like a couple
months later you need a video about Luke
so get out of time that yeah that out I
heard about it well before and I was
watching it because I wanted to be able
to recognize them and then we got to the
point where we could like actually see
their face in the spider-man suit
looking over so now then they did a
video and Kolby person to living room
and you could see Colby person that's
you're 12 yeah on the wall and I was
like man this does not get any better
than this alright let's get into the
news yeah yeah we ready new all the time
alright roll the bumper let's do this
[ __ ] like I wouldn't do that
I wouldn't crawl up there I just
wouldn't do that and crawl up there
it's kind of creepy there it was like
when I said hem with that real to any
kind of creepy shadow masters use let
them know hey all right Dan
so what up guys so for the news today
top story is some breaking news actually
I don't know if you guys heard about
this I think this this is just in the
last four hours or something right front
friend of the show could you call him
that no no no okay doubly not friend of
the show
Martin Martin shkreli is that it yeah
record really good freckie Latino sure
Crowley I think that's actually
accurately voted one of the most hated
man in America well uh for for all those
people that voted him as the most hated
I guess good news uh he he has been
convicted on federal fraud charges Wow
yeah you guys three three of eight
charges including securities fraud can
carry a maximum sentence of 20 years in
federal breaking events for reference
yeah no yeah younger there's going to be
you know him by name Martin shkreli if
you guys don't know he's this guy who
like found this obscure drug to treat
kids with cancer and he's like instead
of five I'm gonna charge a thousand is
the pharma boy yeah Pharma bro he was a
you know I was with Eric rim it's to
deal with toxoplasmosis was right a
parasite that you guys so he's like [ __ ]
these kids with AIDS [ __ ] these kids oh
my god so the reason even though that's
a very douchey thing to do that's not
actually why he's going to prison
because that is not illegal but what he
was again a whole slew of ya know he was
a so he was being tried for eight
different charges basically he was kind
of pulling a mini Bernie Madoff you
remember that whole thing he was ripping
off a hedge fund and basically an
elaborate Ponzi scheme is the best way
to describe it was he was essentially
paying off credit card debt with more
credit cards right exactly and uh
singing into his own
funding for the companies that he owns
right and I wish there was video of this
I guess by all reports because anybody
that that's followed this guy knows that
he's kind of an [ __ ] no no it wasn't
funny no well then he must be not I went
into one of his eyes time just once and
he was like yeah I've seen some of your
stuff I just don't think you're that
funny I was in the middle of ever
telling him that he enjoyed boys
sandwiches though I guess a logical
reaction he wanted to make a vapenation
collaboration with us when we were in
New York
yeah really yeah we almost made a video
with inner lattice oh boy I feel like if
you enter this guy's life in any way
he's like gonna bring you there I'm like
sure old yeah and I have fifty million
dollars in my bank account so I'm going
to sue you and have you someone come
rape your grandma for a laugh that was
one of them but him being is so like is
such a troll like you can't even have a
conversation with him that was the main
reason that it didn't happen because
they Ethan and him had some kind of like
a tweet exchange and he just I couldn't
advanced on what he was saying it's like
too meta
two minutes yeah and interest I'm
unfortunate yeah still have the Wutai
obelisk of course yeah and that question
even more criminal than they absolutely
doesn't know about the guy because I
care about looting they're like discuss
the one that bought that album from the
reserves like we're never going to hear
it I really there's a clause in that
contract that says that the wu-tang can
do a heist with Bill Murray to go get it
better it goes into the slammer oh it's
all that ice becomes like a million
times easier to do yep
you know why the point you bought that
whooping album for a million bucks yeah
that seems like a pretty lowball number
doesn't it well that's what they were
selling it for right or was it an
auction I don't like they can hold it
for a million bucks
yeah it all stood up for a million I
guess but I guess where's my whizzers
attempt at making music art how am I
saying here who someone is staring in
the chat that he played it today on
video Oh what whoa look at my [ __ ] yeah
I will religion think it was recorded
I'm sure it'll show up okay good what
dot CEO in other news the new whooping
albums out sorry yet so unfortunately
there's no video of this at something
that sounds so appropriate for him
apparently as they were reading off you
know the sentences you know he was found
not guilty on the majority of them
actually there's eight charges and five
of them he was not guilty on and he he
was just smiling smugly and then they
got to the chart and they were like okay
and securities fraud found guilty and he
was completely [ __ ] shocked like he
did not expect to lose at all he was
very cocky makes it all the sweeter
really you know and you should find some
of his life right now streaming by the
way really really oh yeah you're gonna
send someone a frickin burger my grandma
now going to jail lol I remember that
quite a bit yeah it does you should find
that the the courtroom sketches the
people done of them because it seems as
if the people doing the courtroom
sketches like don't hold him in high
regard they give them yeah he looks like
a [ __ ] cartoon character while
everybody around him looks normal well
to be fair oh I mean yeah let me say wow
that is not kind you're right look at he
looks like a frickin yeah right one
always [ __ ] I'm sorry lawyer Goblin
who's that right it's a what the [ __ ]
yeah spider-man why are you having
else's debts they are not kind to him it
doesn't look like him at all oh my god
you're so on point with that one Defoe
reference holy [ __ ] I know that's he
looked alone yeah and it's it oh yeah uh
the person drawn it like yeah I draw me
good he's not as I'm making Martin
shkreli look bad than he did making
other people look like at all like you
tried and I really got a knowledge
shkreli Chris gorgeous Martin wish you
the best
Lea little murder me or my grandma yeah
you know him and so Flo could play a
good game of chess I bet his he clumped
you should ask them because I don't
think he's a good album
that's a hot hair well if it's in
Clinton they would hate him shut up a
dog oh yeah listen oh man
alright what's next alright so Oh looks
like Michael Jackson on reading story um
let's see here or do you guys hear about
this okay so uh
you guys are familiar with the cathedral
notre-dame yeah in Paris yeah sure so
not that one but you know but you know
the the other one in Ottawa Canada no
probably not huh yeah well I would I was
not aware of it either
until I saw this story Ottawa
Archbishop's surprised by the negative
reaction to the robotic spider on their
Cathedral is that a prop from wild wild
west so this was a part of some big art
convention or our festival that was
happening in in Ottawa and this this is
a fully [ __ ] animatronic robots that
is elaborate pretty elaborate you know
the church had no idea that Wild West
was coming in no the church was down for
it apparently and then the line would be
the flock tours I was pretty offended by
this and the the archbishop had to
apologize now well that little didn't
convey is there was there's more than
just the spider that was this dragon is
already fairly oh no it hell yeah but
that's like not that God doesn't stand
for that yeah that's the discovery store
any minute I think you guys would
appreciate the ability to blow fire my
created I have are I do questioned that
arc bishops judgement can we have a
demonic dragon who breathes fire come
Mike was in front of our church yeah you
know what that sounds cool actually yeah
oh Willy iTunes get into it anyway you
got a chessboard in front okay watching
an album wait how do we play rearrange
that I mean you want I communicated with
them at one point the Soflo thing Martin
if you're listening DME or phone number
and we'll call you let me make sure I so
so this is what we call you if you are
on this alien may or may not post your
phone number into the
which is next one now jump oh yeah I'm
excited I said though [ __ ] [ __ ] robot
spiders dude yeah seriously pharma bro
spiders talked it was he being right on
twitter something yeh was oh god this
guy's yeah I remember active on tourists
I only had how do I contact the guy
alright the phone number is apparently
like even in the chat right now so
people just spamming his phone number
yeah because we already gave it look
how's he gonna know yeah yeah don't work
out which one is you yeah I'm not gonna
I'm not Brian can try it right on his
stream right now he just said that yeah
Ryan tried that phone number in the chat
on their heads and you catch Martin let
us know anyone will keep continuing on
with the news right in here it just
gives his phone number no I believe but
how am I gonna I'm not going to sit here
in calls number 30 times yeah how does
he know which ones you also I'm not sure
that I trust that guy with my phone
number
good one like he's gonna cone on stream
he's gonna get ahead and Uganda filter
it'll be Ryan call him Iowa alright
Martin we can set it up for next week if
you're listening we can do it officially
and figure it out that is a Jewish soul
yeah if you're no free man given the
close by jess is here and he wants to
hear the album right yeah not so good
yeah oh yeah oh I'll work it out next
week he's gonna melt it so much yeah
Wilson will work it out
alright what else we got alright so even
you you've expressed on the show and
elsewhere before that you you you hold a
lot of disdain for Facebook right
I thought Facebook as an organization
yet as as an entity or whatever yes
so were you aware that Facebook was
developing a you know some advanced AI
that basically controls all Facebook and
gathers users data and tries to kind of
like tailor [ __ ] to your personal
experience I mean is that mall
experience that to an extent right but
they apparently were developing like a
full-fledge you know neural net computer
thing to analyze all this and they had
to shut it down because started saying
racist [ __ ]
what does that almost it's straight up
come on here we go
invented its own language oh my god
over time the people at Facebook we're
looking at this thing and all of a
sudden the AI like the different
components of it we're talking to each
other in like code oh that couldn't
understand and I miss that it various
kind I'm glad they shut that [ __ ] down
right so that was a cool bit more like
serving right like shut it down yeah
they're like basically they know better
than us they were like this was not seen
this is diesem this picture is unrelated
know that is they actually advanced it
put the AI in that in that body
that's it does look cool yeah smash that
like button so still tell me more this
is fascinated yeah so so they develop
this artificial intelligence and
basically what was happening is you know
within the AI there's these different
entities they call agents that basically
like they bounce off of each other in
order to get late to matrix sounding
yeah and yeah basically and they started
talking in like this weird stuttery way
so that there was some examples so in
one exchange illustrated by the company
the to negotiating Bob's name Bob and
Alice use their own language to complete
their exchange Bob started by saying I
can I everything else to which Alice
responded balls have zero to me to me to
me to me to me
just infinitely and so they're looking
at this and they're just like that
creepy as [ __ ] what the hell are these
things saying yeah and basically I guess
it decided that the English I don't this
is obviously well beyond my
understanding but the AI somehow came to
the conclusion that English is
inefficient and so let's do away with
some balls to me yes I made balls to me
but then that solution in English
yeah and created its own syntax in its
own way of sentencing our creating
sentence structure to kind of speed
everything up and so I mean it at least
to the layman to me that seems like the
beginning of like an AI totally right
runaway train kind of [ __ ] it's the
first step of the singularity right it
literally to kill the computer and it
was
like this asks we're going to do our own
kale the competitive damage do you think
I think did like in the small amount of
time that it was a lot I think like 20
people you can say some tendrils off
like Ultron's itself into the internet
somehow no no that's dope there's
probably some shadows of it like just
sort of laying low right now they're
going to pop up right right right yeah I
mean they've been talking for years that
the you know researchers kind of member
that the internet is going to suddenly
become sentient
like it becomes forget alone this is the
thing to worry about act my business we
help actually yeah what if the AI likes
it is it a he look minor they're just
like excuse their helical owners for
life do you look recorder just run a
tube YouTube every videos Gila kleiner
for less well that's [ __ ] terrifying
let's kill these robots and as I've been
saying for years shut down Facebook they
perpetuate this they created this
monstrous right this scourge on the
planet you know we need to shut down
Facebook if they are against Facebook I
support the a I bring down Facebook
right I'm worried about Mark Zuckerberg
playing a [ __ ] Frankenstein games over
there and is castle he's a clone ruled
by the shadow masters he's making AI
look he's got him looking like 90s
freaking raisin men a silver servers and
I'm getting creeped out did you guys
ever see that video of Mark Zuckerberg
where his his team made some new like a
are kind of thing for the phone it like
puts glasses on your face and he's like
staring into the cameras like hello
everyone just want to say we're working
on some new stuff this one is my
favorite and it's Tim wearing glasses is
that they are I didn't see a whole
conference where they were testing out
VR we seen this and it's a group full of
people with VR staring at the stage and
it looks like some like really
disturbing [ __ ] like literally in an
audience before during the guy playing
VR Garros he looks like Max Headroom
Oh character that Headroom they I do
that original yes I'm not down with this
[ __ ] I tell you what he was the first
thought of science fiction of AI I was
the birth of Max Headroom
I'm not down that's some have you heard
of a herpes
no so there's this new thing when you
have commune
all the art says there's a new virus eye
herpes see there's like VR bars now and
conventions yet I like I am NOT another
night not like ya know how I find out a
mold yes should just pass my I love that
idea too
that's a whole different kind of
variable should work but there's people
in these conventions sharing the same VR
goggles and there's [ __ ] I heard but I
don't know how you take it herpes from a
toilet seat then if you can get them
from a VR headset do those own yeah
that's a that's a good question I think
I think it's just very short a badass a
moisture yeah it's very up close and
personal right my boss from a few years
back like a saccade Muse VR headset and
like I just been running around a lot
and he's like hey check this out and I
put it on and I was really sweaty and
when I took it off I was like I kind of
[ __ ] this up for him didn't I
he's got the clean that's getting my
friend I'm done with it you you're the
one that surprised I gave nation zero at
the very least gave them a little bit of
the irf ease I thought you meant like a
lowercase I yeah I mean that is
possession moment yeah works both hi
herpes all right what's next ants all
right next up so this is kind of a dream
job of mine I couldn't believe this is
real can you show it when you yeah here
we go we've got NASA is looking for
someone to protect the Earth from aliens
this is this is a real job position 125
K to 187 so decent living to become a
planetary defender what is the job our
garden also does they're from guardians
of the galaxy Chris Pratt it was just
our Lord our Lord yeah I mean basically
you can make can you can you make an
alias for yourself like star-lord I'm
gonna go with ya hi herpes so you know
basically NASA is looking to hire
somebody for an initial period of three
years so this is a three-year contract
the job involves preventing alien
microbes from contaminating the earth as
well as ensuring human space explorers
do not damage other planets and moons in
objects in space so it's not just
defending the earth this is defending
all planets this is like a galactic
defender is kind of like Star Wars
yeah it's a good thing to get started
now yeah why exactly what your shadow
fell off so in your new job I got some
background you're on the moon Air Force
experience there you go
any word on the prerequisites the
experience require uh well this video
games count yeah put a magic Space
Invaders probably like halo roller to
open to more modern sillier the role is
open to those with broad engineering
experience and a willingness to travel
to the [ __ ] moon hell yeah since a
minute I mean there's going to be some
travel involved some some sort that
means that there came some alien [ __ ] no
I had to guess I think what it means is
that with us going to the Moon and Mars
and [ __ ] like that
and Europa with like unmanned Scranton
spacecrafts
they're more concerned about us
contaminating those pristine and very
exactly that with microbes for better
the primary thing is they don't want us
to [ __ ] up the rest of the soldiers
one day when they go to Europa and
they're like I think there might be life
here they don't want a contaminated
space probe to take a sample that
actually came from the probe and then it
[ __ ] up the whole experiment so
they're trying to figure out ways to
keep that sterile so that there's no
living microbes going over Mars
lettering about how we evolved that
weren't we from Mars
that's one yeah that is one theory I
like that theory one are you leave that
one it's possible I mean Mars was very
earth-like like three billion years ago
they call it uh something sperm eeeh you
know it's called it's [ __ ] great I'll
go sperm you but nowhere to go something
related to earth it's a great image
because like the theory is a comet comes
in smash into Mars wrote in Mars just on
the earth right and with a little bit
alive and here we are and then all then
you know three billion years later Mars
Carly's going to prison like eggs up
he's like in the middle going okay you
know [ __ ] but what else again so this
one's near and dear to my heart because
somebody that has lived in Los Angeles
my whole life something that that
everybody who lives here even for a
short amount of time knows is that
parking
is super [ __ ] up and it is
ridiculously easy to get a parking
ticket and not only that oh yeah
there is zero [ __ ] way to have any
kind of recourse
like if you're wrongly ticketed like
just [ __ ] you goodbye eat the price on
hill
this man just won six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars wining the city no way
over a [ __ ] up parking ticket and not
only that it's actually going to commute
change the game because I don't know if
you guys are aware but la about like 20
years ago outsource the parking ticket
oh that's yeah they privatized it so
like that so the Xerox planes from here
are your Rock's all goes well yes Xerox
is actually the company that handles all
of the payments and processing and going
after you when you when you don't pay
your ticket and all the [ __ ] and this
guy is like that
that's unbelievable is unfair like
completely unfair and it's a little bit
like they're you know if it's Xerox
they're [ __ ] parking ticket printer
should fail every now yeah it's just
when they get angry what the hell they
[ __ ] they can't make their goddamn
printers work as well as the ones that
they charge people for for those are the
good one parking an inch into the red
right so this guy spent years fighting
this is started in 2014 and he spent
three years battling the city over a
sixty five dollar ticket what a hero
yeah and in lawyer fees he probably came
out with
he's probably breaking you take five but
more importantly so he won the lawsuit
but what the lawsuit did is essentially
prove that that what the city's been
doing privatizing the whole deal is
completely illegal so they're going to
have to redo that because what he proved
is they were just Auto declining like if
you can they weren't even looking at it
they were just like oh yeah sure there's
no value to the old you know move well
yeah yeah it's low [ __ ] damn but so you
were right that and and yeah now we may
actually get some relief because I don't
know about you guys but I've gotten
[ __ ] by that many times we were there
just the other week let's video okay oh
it 15 minutes after two
or something first of all when the
partner paid the meter ya left for like
yeah 15 minutes come back with a [ __ ]
$65 ticket yeah and it was like I think
you're over the time like 15 like it was
a don't park here here after 6 o'clock
at the Attucks 15 but there were like
three signs that were like conveying
different things and that's other than
today today to me really make it
confusing yeah somebody that I fix and
go oh yeah Dallas yeah yes I'm on from
but like bonzi that there's a steer
I mean ok first of all there's a [ __ ]
state tax of 10% I don't need some gut I
pay taxes I pay a lot of taxes I don't
need some troll hiding in every [ __ ]
bush waiting to ticket my ass
when all the signs are conflicting and
confusing and I even paid the [ __ ]
meter $2.00 for two hours and now some
[ __ ] going to come out and scam me
it's such a scam dude I'm ready to
overthrow the government when I know you
can win some money off it the parking
authority afterwards I guess what it's
just what I needed in a lager this I
just always look if I see somebody
getting a ticket and failure I'd see
them getting towed I'd run up to my car
and I'd give them a call
really don't be taking that fight with
them for like a good 10 minutes and
anybody my car and I'd walk off good
[ __ ] I get it doubled it
Billy parking meter people like they
tell you they're relentless
they're the water they're one of the
worst they're one you know it I'll show
about that it old memory like this it's
a real it was a reality show about meter
maids I think that specifically in
Philadelphia that's going to be
soul-crushing jobbing what because
you're you everybody hates you yeah yeah
everybody hates your ass hopefully they
get paid well but you come in like they
just remember that last time they got a
ticket like you don't even have to be
giving them a ticket they already hate
you
yeah well [ __ ] them and [ __ ] all of them
what else we got official all right so
last story today oh yeah yeah yeah of
course no one so this one's uh this
one's kind of weird
I asked Ethan beforehand because he grew
up in the area but he wasn't super
familiar with it this is this is a
distinctly Los Angeles thing but I find
it really fascinating because the whole
story is just insane so through the 80s
and the 90s there's this woman in LA
known as Angeline you know about
Angelina you know that Angela you okay
great
at least somebody does so I'm not just
slowly hanging here so Angeline a table
is a staple of LA I would see her [ __ ]
growing up all the time now let me let
me show you some images of Angeline
so this was her thing she bought all of
this billboard space way everyone's
saying II think Oh Martin how much for
you they're saying that he's in the chat
and that he donated he did okay so when
it's like in the donation I hold on let
me get to the bomb okay hold on I know
Susan oh don't worry Martin we're
comment we're coming we want to get your
statement on the red I see the donations
it's streams information pharma former
bro ms all right here we go
yo what is what if Martin's got like
Hillary's emails I feels like dropped
her on I'm too drunk and tired for this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
farmer bro is one of the fish I have in
the number you don't have to do it in
this farm to grow 20 bucks Martin come
on I know you better than what sound
Babu things out for heads up fools call
me he wrote a summary said give me that
special guest I mean that's a nice
enough way to pose it I think that that
thing is that I think that he deserves
better
yeah than just this last minute like
sounds like more better back yeah like I
feel that this is a great reply mout for
next week but you know it is the news of
today so maybe he does have a statement
where he wants to make usually after a
conviction it takes a while he's got
he's got time to like he probably won't
go to prison to my rescure you're good
Martin don't worry about it you're rich
you'll be fine I want to have Martin on
but nobody's going to see it at this
deep in the show yeah they're about the
island we're about to end it just
[ __ ] guy got oil don't we guys have a
cliffhanger
alright a podcast Gordo can you guys
film our next week who do we have next
week do we not have anyone like oatmealy
mm-hmm let me see what's going on there
sound that's a Google Hangouts ring well
who is that is it on this somebody that
you have we can hack
this laptop right here is getting Google
called just close it all right I'll call
I'm gonna call him I want to use Ryan's
number how is it isn't I wait to do call
from unknown
I could call from Skype before I can you
call from Skype that's kind of a yeah
well I mean never told it maybe you guys
can set up the cliffhanger for next week
idea but I need I need to call him but I
know offence Martin because you're a bit
of a troll I don't necessarily trust you
with my phone number but give him mine I
would give a [ __ ] he already said you're
not funny you guys already have beat I
know it'll be it'll be a but I feel bad
I can feel like I'm not going to use
mine but err to the [ __ ] wolf
whatever so we have Martin shkreli phone
number we got it no we're trying to
decide should call render like an easy
way to call someone unmanned oh and from
your phone how do I put my toilet
yeah really does that work sure they sir
private this is your phone all right
Martin i'ma try to call you but we'll
just do a quick like hey how are you
yeah set it up for like you know doing a
thing if you guys give me do like a so
much shot out there that was available
yeah okay let's get Jessie really wants
the zoo thing out so we need a star star
six overs right I try not been this
close I'm glad not working them try it
on me on wait and then I just typed the
number yeah how much i calling you ela
mmm we're figuring it out Martin
thinking about happen okay it's calling
you does it show unknown
yeah private number Wow here we go ah
star six seven Emily dials number oh man
thank you guys so much for having me on
this podcast I've seen so many little
breaking news things first time I'm on
its Jake Paul alright here we go
we got shkreli stressed out he'll be
fine
he knows he's used to this by now
my hello
I got a hang-up they answered they hung
up that's weird now he's got my number
all the fun of it was probably good
trapped you [ __ ]
alright were called your ass he didn't
answer we tried what didn't you give it
a try to try it again because there
might be a lag with the with the stream
but he clicked our I travel I travel
America and just go hey it's Ethan so I
mean this is [ __ ] bananas I loved it
I loved every second of this this is the
art I decided I twist our six seven so
this is that good juice table you know
because we do a lot of prank calling
your prankster by the I professional
Atticus is also shopping clothings he
didn't record it well at karaoke machine
yeah I used to call the prayer lines
with my brother when we really drink I
think I did I have yeah I used to get
some good prayer calls yeah oh my god
that's a funniest one don't pray for
anything as soon as he picks up I once
got him to say kill the Jews I got hung
up on I was like can you Martin that's
how it starts and I mean I'm calling the
number although it may not necessarily
be him maybe it's not he just gave you a
fake note I was assuming people knew
because he's also a life so I was
assuming he's he maybe he's letting
calls over and over here they say
private hang up probably another one
hanged
well it just as farmer bro NSO could be
anyone but I'm glad I didn't use my real
number because if it's just some random
[ __ ] person yeah yeah yeah well we
tried Martin I guess you have to give a
official statement what war real
reporters we'll work it out their
Instagram do to diems on that Instagram
yeah I can phone i'll follow you on
Instagram Martin let me see just saw it
this whole last part of this is just
trying to [ __ ] well this is so nice oh
yeah I mean they're saying what I was
assuming that they saw him do it on his
stream so it's oh he's probably getting
spammed with a million calls yeah well
as they gave his number yeah ok Wilbur
oh I mean I guess what Martin would say
can I just guess that he would say this
was a witch-hunt
maybe they found a couple brooms
yeah yeah definitely
as that is literally what he said I want
to say I think you said that I think you
said how do you files last name on phone
lines to go s h k r li SI chart you know
sh k re i don't know that he has a okay
here Martin shkreli there's a bunch of
pics up to CL boy sandwich into the
phone
no no means I don't know which ones him
[ __ ] I'm gonna get ahold of this guy
well we don't need to do now this
accounts private all right Martin we'll
figure it out
I definitely do want to talk to you and
thanks for the $20 if you want to prove
that it's you you're gonna have to get
up it up a little more Lauren you
started this you got money you know like
don't it oh I got an ad but I heard us
on his trim wait he's on twitch right
now on YouTube
oh you streaming on you he's watching
our stream right now yes this this
stream has devolved into the hell all
right what does it say
Darian what are you saying alright maybe
we can talk to him this yeah here open
it on your TV how do we set it up right
then sir Ram short today this is this is
news yeah yeah there's a lot of it if
you get another meeting with the Secret
Service after this for some reason I'm
going to do this in the [ __ ] up way
ever
all right let's plug it in barn we're
coming for you don't worry Martin we're
gonna get your statement but we need to
know so Martin scurvy looking for him on
YouTube Oh live now okay okay we are
okay all right so I have you open I
don't hear myself on your streamers in
there this is CNN this is just right
Martin oh there's a minute long delay
this is just like CNN guys this sound
must be such a nightmare for people
watching
he said h3h3 is yeah okay I mean I can
hear you don't feel right just a ch3
send help
barn you could talk I can get that we
didn't hear hear
oh my gosh why are you writing [ __ ]
alright Hillary yeah just pick up your
phone
we're good Martin this is not going to
work no this is going to work great this
is the most dynamic unity in the timer
at work is it here view over from one
live stream to another Wow all right
mine how are you how you doing how you
feeling all right Martin we're just
going to stop getting a panic I was
still talking and then he can drunk all
right what's your area code soldier and
you tell me tell me the area code that
you'll call from um and then I'll pick
up that phone it's 702 we are the wait
20 minutes with this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is amazing right let me try one
more time Martin to tell you by the way
Martin was that you who donated and if
it was 20 bucks dude come on
okay how long is it would I look at what
[ __ ] one seven two nine
it's busy you're getting too many
clothes it's not us no not that
all right this is the nightmare no it's
not it is amazing not on call
can can we just get a statement from him
he answered somebody else that's not a
Martin yeah shall I tell him Duncan he
can hear it I hope you will in like 20
it's not not Orion Martin that's where I
know birdy mute it and the nice thing
you know Wow no going huh cut it this
dude's a [ __ ] clone this is a colonic
alone for sure but on the sounder ice
can see only moon from the private
number again can you set up a thing like
Vince you have a way to set up without
how can you say to me privately yeah
yeah we don't have what is your email
like [ __ ] you can give you a link yes
yes Martin give me your email I'll email
you for my official email nobody can
else can you email you from this email
then is he going to want to wait like 20
there's more than one 702 number Martin
[Laughter]
well listen to a listen to this string
hello huh is he [ __ ] with us no this
is like the second worst thing to happen
to him today
[Laughter]
alright what why don't you listen put on
the down low I know where this one
[ __ ] Martin live streaming I think
he's forgotten that we're here already
Oh buddy today was the second think
again and then what about a discord
thing oh my god he keeps answering 702
numbers
I mean dress is going and another late
night call I call maybe you'll get it
you'll get on there you'll get a me
there Jesse saying call so I'm going to
try one more time
I think this is this is worth it you
[ __ ] kidding me right now
barn can you hear it yes okay okay all
right yet just say your email Martin and
I'll email you for my official email you
notes me I'll give you a discord link
for Christ's sake oh my god this is good
right yeah you know oh that guy we would
be such a better call for him right now
right yeah I have more to say than that
yeah a little bit
oh my god we're here bro he's still and
it's not putting on the stream volume
where is it this is an answering mmm
I'll shine I'll shoot prod
what is he doing I think he just keeps
answering calls but I'm gonna keep
calling him [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I'm
calling no this is what he sounds like
right now he must be game like that
thousand call someone tell him to email
us somebody said he answered the phone
integer and calling him tone with you
bill puts it his room oh man this is to
make like an initiative live see if
anybody's actually tone to do it
did he block the chat because there you
go Martin yeah ding free mailing
everybody's on it okay thank you
he can hear us now okay Martin give me
your email address and I'll email you
for my official email and we'll set up
on discord
email is just a Martin this word iron s
Patrol calm not a show you're a computer
well what do I do
what is this game you're the producer
well I didn't show anything okay Martin
has saw modulus to the what he said
thought that I was brought to you by
wine did he actually say martinet
thought watch could somebody help
I'm having a panic attack someone and
this nightmare okay turn it off I'm
dying turn off the TV or something
I can't let me hear man's answer is it
Martin I thought lodge this is like a
episode of Twin Peaks
oh he like Sibylla said you're so funny
all right turn off yeah I'm getting I'm
down okay I'm gonna log in to my
official and you want to stop which roll
tide roll okay Martin Martin I'm
emailing you from work with h3 at
gmail.com Martin I thought patrol calm
thought is th ot right I'm good I see
thin I can't hear ourselves five anymore
I just muted I don't have the remote
okay okay thank you I'm God
alright oh my god still doing a panic
attack I'm telling you guys I get to
squeeze on this one no okay give me it
hook me up a discord in how do I give
this guy discord link right go into here
you're going to okay just wants to play
like public game for a quick kiss okay
Martin at th ot patrol calm I says hi
Ethan is from work with h3 at gmail.com
okay I sent you a discord link
this is [ __ ] bastard and then you
commute history because one need to
hardly are not going to be the interview
is in prison maybe this art that'll be
for lifetime Hill me Nathan it alright
so I'm gonna I'm going to mute his
stream I'm going to open discord so now
I should see him joining hopefully I
didn't just show the link mmm no oh I
think I see him typing yep he's here
he's here oh thank Christ okay yeah okay
go into voice Jim okay now can you hear
me well we have this muted in theory one
sec Martin god this is this is really
something in there how do I wanted to do
a podcast but I figured yeah a bit too
much it's worth it it's a nightmare
it's a crushing nightmare and it's great
but it's a nightmare okay well where's
my word would my mic be coming from it
would be the internal built in one I'm
sure this is on this yeah no I don't
think this has a lot Mike you saw I'm
sorry Liz yeah most of them do oh that's
this one thanks I'm not sure that it
would talk to him with this court if it
does that like so well get me another
laptop okay yeah you do it'll run you
know we're just tossing it out for the
next time this happens we're gonna have
to set up a legit guest appearance this
is just a hey how you doing oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's how Martin operates you know
whose word razz tough that you know okay
bring this here yeah this is the big
fire I've ever this is something yeah
kind of
all right Martin hold on one sec we're
trying to figure this out you put that
in there yeah Oh Koopa Troopa
head engine and then how do I get it so
they can hear oh they can hear from this
plug in goes the plug-in and then
just make sure oh yeah best podcast ever
I wouldn't
I'll put headphones into it intro is
seriously dying here for a moment you
didn't like that sound inception Martin
can you hear me yeah all right we did it
where it is all right Martin how are you
good how are you feeling oh good you
know there was a chance but the
government could put me in jail for 10
years and find me 20 million dollars but
right now looking at 0-6 mama really
here to six months and no fine
this is that zero to six in prison or
house arrest I think that's going to be
a judge but by the book it you know okay
so you so you kind of seeing it as a win
and the media is kind of being like oh
he's guilty but you got off like you
kind of got off yeah there are the
charges
the most serious charges count done the
jury voted not guilty what which one was
that it was this crazy idea that I hold
from my own company to pay back my
investors which I I don't know how it
makes any time so they pried I think
they were just hoping that people were
like oh that's Pharma bro he's guilty
whatever right and that's it work
he's come pretty happy but I gotta tell
you it was under record things because
the jury started out with uncountable on
the jury finds him not guilty not play
smiling in like an IRA we're gonna win
counter not guilty and then calculation
like well it doesn't kill someone
she said that rate and she's like well
yeah I got you guys a on this line so
the ones the ones you are found guilty
on I mean did you do it oh no I don't
think so
you know it's subjective that basically
the question is did you do it with an
intent to do with an intent to steal and
I need $31,000 over four years running
those hedge funds and the investors made
three or four times
so it just doesn't seem to me like
that's the kind of you know criminal in
and that you know my criminal intent I
were told well look Martin like George
will their monies Orin did you ever lie
to these guys you don't miss a question
okay and it's still about in tennis
right so I don't think I lied at all but
even if there was a lie the questions
did the person has an intense and I
don't know man I don't have criminal
intent that's my right you're sleeping
on the floor to get the job done
yeah the average person who has criminal
intent to steal money if they're buying
Maserati they're hanging out with girls
of the playbook and again find wu-tang
albums for a million dollars many here
by the way whatever happened with that
did you ever really set to the matches
no but I'm happy to get your copy really
why Holy Smoke yo hook me up good idea
you get that [ __ ] so this is in session
next part yeah how is that one by the
way is it good you can use Holy Flint
element was not the way spawns on
everyone I feel like oh yeah like super
rich is a dependable bad for them
because they were like you know usually
which hangout would sell like ten
million dollars of Records and the fact
that if I opportunity it was like a net
that would happen that was a great
outcome for them like it was like you
guys are legends you know I felt the
same way I'm really surprised that they
like it almost doesn't make sense why
would they sell for solo my surely they
would made more selling it online to
consumers right will their last album
only sold 50,000 copies and that ten
bucks off you know it's 500 grand
so really sheesh what happened Jesus in
this o little bar basically would a
little bit but why duh why did you like
hold it so close to the chest for so
long I actually watched you release it
and you don't want so isn't there like
an 800 year a limit yeah something like
that
like I can't release for 800 years 88
years way the person who buys it camera
Lycia yeah so that's [ __ ] up because
everyone was [ __ ] on you
yeah I can't really I try to leak it and
they [ __ ] call me and there is
they're not [ __ ] weak anymore ah why
on earth would they not want ideas it
was the RZA doing something artistic in
like y'all wanna I want my music to be a
piece of art and they wanted to go in an
auction like a painting would but then
you know buddy I think like you like he
wanted the people have to go to a museum
and go to listen to it and stuff like
that I think that was like I said of it
after 88 years in general just when it
came out he was open some some artists
or some art gallery would buy it and put
it in their art gallery and elicit so
you got to go there and listen Martin
what are the chances Raekwon and Method
Man are going to kick your door down
when your way for 0 to 6 months with
redshift back zero but this month is no
guarantee they yeah you can have a guy
just waiting in the like with a samurai
sword ready to do [ __ ] battle I just
totally like to put it in a and like
this event mountain and like have a good
of a mix of treasure map guard it as you
can kill them then you get yell them you
know if you do that live log it yeah
well I have to be a part of that in any
way no can't we can help produce that
well um is the ODB on the album he is oh
[ __ ] what that raises the you you
actually got God the wave for a million
that's pretty good for someone released
Cody big yeah I just you guys creating
button if you can make one hundred
million dollars but you had to go to
jail how much time would you do is just
relate it to your situation
totally totally unrelated because you
just sitting here thirty thousand
dollars and it's like your answer with
sarcastically yeah it seems to be a
little bit of in the automotive a
situation seems every time as you do i I
mean for how much 100 mil hundred
million in fact way what is that
whatever you [ __ ] Tony's all-around
of you for a hundred million dollars how
much time would you do yes
just money how much time would I do yeah
am I like you're the orange is the new
block is it on the expense of people
yeah who suffers yeah did you need
straight-up like X hey survey year
here's a bunch of money Oh his uppers
what would you do here what would you do
your only key to 0 to 0 30 okay 0 to 30
days why are you asking it is my like my
business especially it says that even if
you assume I'm guilty which which I'm
not coming out of this with over a
million dollars and like I asked my
lawyer I said well don't boast how is
how would you do for the same and he
said you're talking about minimum
federal prison camp where you're
probably and ago you'd like two years
under two years till you think you did a
good exchange here we're needing your
recommenders Act is that every time you
do business you take a risk and every
time you're an [ __ ] like me they can
use bigger risk and you know minute if I
look into the hall and say like okay was
this whole the last five years of my
life worth it I don't know man soon was
not bad are you talking 100 million
pre-tax or post tax oh yeah sure
I'm talking about your money like it's
maybe over season you know god it
doesn't even pay taxes oh boy what is it
what is it that people misunderstand
about you because you have like two
parts of you like when I hear you now or
during your live stream you seem like a
pretty reasonable down-to-earth guy but
there's also this kind of I mean it
there's also a little bit of a
sociopathic vibe that I get when I see
you smiling like a maniac and talking
about making 100 million dollars in
exchange for going to prison like is
there something like worse the truth lie
I don't know sociopathic maniac at all
but you know I mean sometimes difficulty
things holistically like that's what if
you assume about many I would say for
example at five years my wife Dalkon is
I've made an enormous my line and I also
have a prison it does you are I'm not
connecting this VIN angle good question
is you know is that a series of outcomes
like if you don't make no money humans
prison for 20 years I was on the record
connected the moat if you made a hundred
million dollars and you never have a
prison that
oh it's right over shade out that's sort
of the question you know it's strange
that like in your head money in prison
are in bed together somehow that it's
like it's just those inaudible parts of
my life subtle okay no you know if I
would need a hit album you know and
without a list but that's basically what
the last five years my life is summed up
too right Martin what is it
what are your a big part of like I saw
that Vice interview with you where the
reporter came with you and you guys
played chess and you drank some good
wine and you had a really interesting
point where you were like you know in a
way you're kind of exposing what these
other companies do because there is a a
great amount of much worse than anything
someone could accuse you of doing
happening in other companies that is
just like completely swept under the rug
is that still a message that you're
putting out there I mean I don't have
anything bad to say about the
pharmaceutical industry I've had so many
friends die of diseases I friend now
they're dying of those diseases and of
AIDS is not going to fix them
unfortunately the they're either based
maple this yeah the the drug industry
makes great medicines for these kids and
they have to keep doing that so it's a
money driven business for sure but I
think it's a good bit plus so I don't
have anything bad to say about the drug
business at all
I was we've got the people in the drug
business well you know I think most of
them are pretty well meaning I think
they want to create medicine ball change
diseases let's do the [ __ ] alone but
come on yeah you feel like you're just
like a kind of a easy target after that
big story broke about you the first time
and now everyone should sell for blood
to kind of be like hey we got one of
them yeah absolutely but I also love to
troll I mean there's nothing more fun
than to make up something ridiculous and
watch people believe it and watch them
tie themselves in knots over it's that's
so satisfying I think you know that
yourself you know with something like
humongous I become like every day my
life is is that dude and
you know it's awesome you know like I
love triggering people it's an ethic and
medicine is something very massive my
life's work so you know when people sort
of called me farmer girl and they
thought that signal was terrible side I
just sort of took it in stride and yeah
absolutely on the fiblet and I'm totally
a villain in and just sort of ran with
it and it
nobody's ever stopped and said yeah you
know that's not true
they sort of still persistence and is
that how you wanted to be seen though
like didn't you did you ever want to be
seen as like the farmer here oh oh
time will tell you know like there are
people that were totally to discuss you
know hated and people were disgusted by
people like Bill Gates even and how
everyone thinks he's the greatest going
to ever but for a while here's a
swashbuckling capitalist monopolist that
put out a business all the competitors
you just got started charity yeah now
he's a terrible guy but when he was my
age he was talking to trying to never
ever look what what what's martin
shkreli's malaria going to be yeah I
heard he made a one drug for a very
disease called pecan that seems to cure
it um but I also Bill Gates gave or he's
like giving away like billions of
dollars to a non-profit yes yes given
invented any medicines I have yeah but
that that's a enterprise yeah that's
like saying Bill Gates made software and
so he's a saint I mean you're running a
business yeah he made his fortune
software and he's donating a now to all
sorts of great causes and they should be
commended only thing is that while he is
making a fortune people made fun of his
haircut I agree a fun way he needed
money to government trying to goldman
criminal they have these big antitrust
hearings where you know they almost
brought criminal charges on Microsoft
and now he's lauded aterial say time
will tell you know I'm going to make as
many great job as I can and I'm going to
try to make money as I can at anytime
I'm gonna hear about that night we might
a long ways to go and become so glad as
charges didn't are not going to set me
back in any way which was my big fear
you know I want to hear about the night
where that the news first came out where
you raise the price of daraprim they
might pronounce
right yeah you raise the price of it and
that night a lot of news came out and
people were tweeting you and you jumped
onto Twitter and you were responding to
people but though your responses were
like you were saying like sort of the
trolling triggering kind of thing do you
think that maybe that might have been
the the incendiary action that caused
what people thought of your character I
don't think I would have been indicted
them if it's trial if you would just not
if you would handle that differently and
maybe Ben because you were also it's
like after that you went on the record
explaining exactly what you did and you
changed a lot of people's minds don't
you think if you had done that right off
the bat so I try though I really did and
I think the response was so weird the
only reaction I could have I'm gonna
roll back and that was the night we
talked do you remember my video of you
yeah you called me a YouTube comedian I
think I made funny for not being able to
like reach the the tall shelf at the
grocery store something like that I
a lot of people made on me hahaha it was
it was the night to do it Martin it was
the night to do it
I'm I'm hoping that over time the record
would be clearer and a lot of people
don't understand when welcome but Martin
I'll always remember you for that
Harambee report you did no matter
whatever charities you do whatever you
go out whatever the government throws at
you I will always remember you for that
Harambee piece you did on the news gamba
not forgotten
also what I have what you always doing
streams like you're always on stream and
it's like you sitting like by yourself
you seem kind of lonely are you lonely
like you're sitting in a room by
yourself and it's like you're talking to
these random people on the internet it's
just like the guys got a hundred million
bucks wu-tang album and he's just
sitting in a room by himself and I'm
like this guy seems kind of lonely yeah
I mean not always been myself like
becoming wealthy hasn't changed the
personality at have which is always kind
of a loner
um and what can I say you know that's
who I am I like to work I like to roll
around
computer a bunch of chicks you know the
celebrity is sort of yeah I was just
just remembering I was looking at your
followers on Twitter the people who you
follow and 90 percent of them were like
cam girls no I swear to God go to the
tapes not swear to God I was looking to
your fathers and they're all like cam
girls and like Connor Martin whoa hey
dude did you get laid because people got
mad at you for raising the price of a
drug I think there's people that for I
don't know why we've been honestly
annoying it but yeah I have no idea I
have no [ __ ] clue
I would imagine part of it 100 million
of them I am and my colleague is yeah I
know but they like to be treated you
said I'm going to give us some nice wine
play a good game of chat and then their
name you know they're your wife I think
a lot of them have delusions like I'm
going to marry them and get half yeah
also does anyone ever roleplay with you
like like tell me sell me some [ __ ]
arms of a human are so pleasant oh yes
Martin yeah isn't happened yeah any oh
that's a shame that would be a red flag
would be control next time you're with
the girl hey will you roleplay that I
just raised the price of this drug all
right I think that's all we have for
today Martin Vega solid really fun I
really appreciate you jumping on that
was really really a cool conversation I
appreciate it a lot
Thanks the juice was worth the squeeze
let's uh let's stay in touch
I mean yeah let's let's stay in touch
all right cool Martin take care of luck
buddy yeah good luck out there
Harambee bless very good copy of that
album
yeah send us that copy I'll talk to you
in an email we just out CNN CNN what
[ __ ] all right well that's a wrap
we did it I thought that was great I'm
really glad you guys I was rooting for
it to happen Hamid that news about him
happened today about yeah yeah yeah
what do you think what do you mean
what's your take on Martin you know what
I just paid my taxes all these offshore
[ __ ] that's one thing I can say
you for sure that's this and I don't
have a good million yeah I mean you know
he's uh he's an arrogant guy he knows
how to talk you know said it defuse a
situation like when he wants to it's not
it's not necessarily a negative thing
when I say he's an arrogant guy right
you know he's there's an endearing
quality to the way that he does it but
he's still an arrogant guy
well the question of like is he a
sociopath maybe the thing is a guy that
didn't get much attention growing up you
figure something out as well look at all
this attention yeah and then he was just
flew off the handle bars when you said
when he kind of the way he reacted
really like that and little it was
attention and I like [ __ ] with people
so I'm gonna be a huge dick I don't I
don't know that can I'm rich so don't
was it gonna affect me I don't know if
he's the one who deserves to go to
prison because there's probably like
what I was trying again sorry [ __ ] on
these other [ __ ] companies he's
probably people who do like way worse
and they're just smarter we're just
getting away with what is yeah they
don't boast they don't walk up to it's
hard to know I would rather [ __ ] the
integra cares to know it's hard to know
if you're not on the jury yeah it's
really hard to know what's happening but
like I don't know if he's putting on the
show of like hey I'm just a normal sweet
guy and the world doesn't end understand
me you know it's alright but I all I
know is it like that night when he when
the news story was like still hot off
the press and he was reacting to people
on Twitter he was saying some dumb [ __ ]
to these people like what oh no I don't
he was saying uh like there was one guy
there's like this reporter who was
coming after him he was like you are
irrelevant no one's listening to you I'm
sorry Martin if I'm getting this wrong I
think I am getting it right though
you're irrelevant no one cares and like
so on and so forth and it's just a very
bad way to handle that sort of attention
and I think maybe he fell into it a
little bit and that would that was the
wrong move to do like he could have done
the thing that he did in the months
following just explaining why I raised
the price I guess I guess what he was
saying is that at first he tried
explaining but nobody was responding to
oh sure yeah no you're a scholar at the
trolling and then he got him with the
explaining either way I know he's
listening something personal we're just
being honest with
this is our hot cake because I you know
I used to it by nightmare to keep in
touch I need Martin shkreli as a [ __ ]
regular I don't know anything about the
guy I don't follow the news that much I
just knew I just know about whoo tang
and they were like this guy's the guy
that bought that album because I was
reading about RZA was gonna do this with
the album and it was this guy and I
think he was on a stream and he had two
album but he was talking [ __ ] about the
rule or some chili or something
trolling it was in trouble is it
something that made everybody angry
about him having the album I feel in the
work he did a shout out to I think
Ghostface like I think he I'm sorry
Martin if I got this wrong again but I
don't think I thought that was like dead
the kind of pistol was handed my neck
some guy designed him yeah it was like
[ __ ] oh yeah I got the album's AOL just
like he was doing something yeah oh he
made a video where he was like with
samurais and he was writing [ __ ] on that
you thought that I liked no limit strong
but on the other hand I see him being
misrepresented too because the way I
understood the story was that he bought
it and he was like [ __ ] the whole world
I'm not going to play over you that was
very what I would that was yours was
supposed to do but there was a clause
well she got us really bought yeah he
said some trash now some trash 188 your
clothes man all right let's wrap it up
Martin thanks for coming on Eric always
a pleasure uh see you thank you ride a
yeah I'm here baby I'm gonna have a real
nice conspiracy corner for you Jesse so
[ __ ] great has been a man you're
saying that first your stories were
absolutely captivating you're killed it
thank you guys and you know you know
what I met a lot of youtubers in this
YouTube world and made friends with them
and a lot of youtubers what you guys
don't know is they're not who they are
in their videos you guys aren't [ __ ]
they're better than their videos okay
not as being real the real deal thank
you thanks ma'am
all right guys thanks for watching hope
you guys enjoyed the ride this was a
long and dirty I feel more like an hour
too bad for me to go back yeah we were
just waiting out there traffic or Jesse
see you guys next Friday boy do we have
a [ __ ] the same guys generally if you
guys know who that is gonna be a
surprise
oh [ __ ]
he's a lunatic he does visa hardly I
known he's like a totally unstable he's
like six-year-olds want to be a comedian
and he just will go on the street we
found him because he made a sketch in
his Dennis office he's really successful
Dennis and he was passing out his
mixtapes to all of his his evolving
reliance and someone's I yelled my room
oh yeah oh yeah and so we found out
because one of his clients was like
this'll lunatic then it's handed me this
mixtape and we watched him went down
this whole rabbit hole of his insanity
and we made it we made videos with him
when we were in New York cuz he's from
New Jersey yeah he saw Jersey yeah this
is the kind of car that's always
bitching about stuff know them now I'll
show it it's humble and it's just one
[ __ ] you guys know yeah you guys know
what I'm sorry about your buddy was
added for next week anyway thanks for
joining us guys we love you appreciate
you and we will see you on the flip my
dogs peace